EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US AT OUR FIRST SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE YEAR IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
AND LYFT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
SAYS NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH NONE OF
OUR COMMUNITY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
SOCIAL. INSERTING HARMONS-
UPTOWN AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUAL TO. TODAY FOR ALL
INTO WITH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE. ONE FOUR ZERO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MORE. PLEASE
REFER TO THIS THAT AND WORK
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED UP COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MONITOR TO TELL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE YOUR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND IN THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE FOR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE HAVE SIX
BILLS. OUR OWN CAN'T OUR
CONSENT. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OF BILLS WE WILL
TRY AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT I
THINK WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND JUST START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR FIRST AUTHOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. PLEASE PROVE- START
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER SARAH PROUD TO
STAND AND PRESENT SB EIGHT FIVE
ONE- CAL GRANT EQUITY AND
COLLEGE ACCESS ACT- TODAY I'M-
PRESENTING THIS. I THINK
POSSIBILE- WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WHICH REPRESENT
OVER EIGHTY INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT ACCREDITED COLLEGES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE INCLUDING
MANY IN MY SECOND THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
COLLECTIVELY THERE ARE MORE THAN
A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATES PURSUING THEIR
EDUCATION AT THESE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES INCLUDING OVER
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS. WHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE MY FAMILY CAN
RELATE TO THAT AS MY FATHER WAS
THE FIRST IN OUR ITALIAN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY. TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AFTER WORLD WAR TWO ONE
THREE I BILL OF RIGHTS AND IT
CHANGED. OUR FAMILY
SIGNIFICANTLY THE SUPPORT AND
QUALITY OF EDUCATION THAT
STUDENTS RECEIVE AT THESE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IS
REMARKABLE. STUDENT TO FACULTY
RELATE RATIO IS ELEVEN TO ONE
GIVING STUDENTS DIRECT ACCESS TO
THEIR PROFESSORS. AT THE
LEGISLATURE IS PRIORITIZE
COLLEGE ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY
AND THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO
SUPPORT BOTH GOALS. AND
PROVIDING DIRECT FINANCIAL AID
SUPPORT THROUGH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WHICH MINIMIZES THE
NEED TO WORK FOR TAKE OUT
EXPENSIVE STUDENT LOANS WHILE IT
IS UNDENIABLY THE MOST ROBUST A. PROGRAM IN THE- CALVET MUST BE
IN IN INFO WAYS. SB EIGHT FIVE
WHAT CAL GRANT AT INCOME ACCESS
ACT WILL STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND
THE STATE SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO
ATTEND I SEE SEE USE. IT WILL
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT SUPPORT
TO STUDENTS PARENTS AND FOSTER
YOUTH AS WELL AS SIMPLIFYING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS THE BILL WILL HELP
PRODUCE AN EDUCATED WORKFORCE
AND HELP CLOSE THE EQUITY GAP.
IT WILL ALSO EXPAND CAL GRANT
SUPPORT TO SEVERAL THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS BY PROVIDING
A MORE STABLE AWARD FOR EVERY
STUDENT. IN SNAP OR MAY IN THE
FUTURE I BELIEVE IN THE VALUE OF
THESE ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
WHICH HAVE A GREAT RECORD OF
GRADUATING STUDENTS IN A VERY.
EFFICIENT FOR YOUR TIME FRAME
WHICH AGAIN IS SOMETHING HELPS
THE STUDENT GETTING WORKS TO GET
EDUCATED AND HELPS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THESE INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDE IN A- MAZING SERVICE TO
A BROAD SPECTRUM STUDENTS. AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS. THESE
TWEAKS TO THE CAL GRANT. TO I
HAVE WITH ME AND I KNOW THE
CHAIR AND I BOTH SHARE AN
AFFINITY TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
REDLANDS AND MANY OF THE STAFF.
IN OUR BUILDING AND OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE GONE TO MANY OF
THESE INSTITUTIONS TODAY I HAVE
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY DOCTOR
AND MEDICAL ANY- JOHNSON
PRESIDENT OF MOUNT ST.
UNIVERSITY ONE OF THE ALL
WOMEN'S COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA
ANDMONTSERRAT PINEDA AN
NDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS WHO IS
THE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT AT CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS
MAJORING IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR PORTANTINO WE WILL NOW
START WITH YOUR LEAD SUPPORTERS
AS YOU JUST INTRODUCED THEM- YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES WE WILL
START WITH DOCTOR IN MAKUENI
JOHNSON PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU ARE YOU
HEAR ME WE ARE. HELLO A GREAT
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
ALL THE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU BRIEFLY
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT WHY THIS THE
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY ONE
MATTER SO MUCH TO OUR SECTOR BUT
ALSO TO SCHOOLS LIKE MOUNT ST
MARY'S UNIVERSITY JUST BRIEF.
CALIFORNIA IN LOS. OUR STUDENTS
ARE- PRIVATE FOR MERRILEES FIRST
. COLLEGE STUDENTS 60% THE FIRST
IN THEIR FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE. 62% ARE PELL.
RECIPIENTS AND- 83% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE WOMEN OF COLOR. AND
WE REALLY REPRESENT YOU I THINK
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR STATE.
AND ALSO I THINK OUR STUDENTS
PROVIDE A COMPELLING REASON WHY
THE CAL GRANT AND THIS BILL IS
SO IMPORTANT. OUR STUDENTS COME
TO US WITH BIG DREAMS AND- WE DO
SEE IT AS A REAL HAVE A SACRED
RESPONSIBILITY ACTUALLY TO HELP
THEM ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS- I WANT
TO SAY THAT THIS. THIS BILL IS
SO IMPORTANT TO US BECAUSE THE
CAL GRANT IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
HELPING OUR STUDENTS ALONG WITH
THE- FEDERAL SUPPORT THROUGH THE
PELL GRANT. AND ALSO OUR
INSTITUTIONAL GRANTS WHICH
AVERAGE AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- FOR EACH STUDENT- DID
THE CAL GRANT. ALLOWED OUR
STUDENTS TO FILL THAT GAP SO
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO ENROLL. AND
GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE IN FOUR
YEARS. UNTIL IT'S CRITICAL TO
OUR STUDENTS- I HOPE THAT- AS
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THIS BILL
YOU'LL- WILL I THAT. THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING THAT
STABILITY FOR STUDENTS. SO THAT
THEY CAN BE ENSURED THAT THAT
GRANT WILL INCREASE INCOME LEVEL
AND THE PROCEDURE COLLEGE. AND
HELP THEM STAY AND ALSO EXPANDED
TO IT. TO HELP THE STUDENT
PARTICULAR. YOU AND OUR STUDENTS
WITH CHILDREN IN THE CROWD SERVE
. SO I WOULD ASK YOU PRESIDENT
MOUNTAIN MARY'S ON BEHALF MARK
YOU. AND ALL ON BEHALF OF- ARC
SECTOR CHIU CONSIDER THIS BROWN
OF THE WAY TO RELEASE. STUDENT
IN OUR STATE. AND ALSO HELP THEM
. SO THEY'RE ABLE TO BE. GOING
TO BE A- I THANK YOU SO. FOR
YOUR- AND- FOR YOUR WITH. IN
DISCUSSING THE STILL. SO MUCH.
NOW WILL BONTA MS MONSTER HOT
PINEDA PLEASE FOR WHEN YOU'RE-
OKAY HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. HELLO
OKAY GREAT GOOD MORNING THE AND
NUMBER OF THE CAN MY NAME IS
MONSTER YEAH I NEVER YOU'RE
PROBABLY MEETING POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND FROM WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO HERE. THE
END OF BECAUSE CALLED I PROGRAM
I CAP WHICH YOU'RE NOT UNIFIED
VOICE THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND THAT ATTENDED. FIVE
THANK COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITIES
IN THE MONEY ON IRAN. TO YOU
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT IS FOR THE
COMPANY TO SUPPORT A FIFTY ONE
IN HOT BUT IT TO KEEP THE
GRAPHIC OF THE STATE. OVER
THOUSAND. TARGET WITH AND I.
SPECIAL I CHOSE TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY ABOUT THEM BECAUSE OF
THE COST MIGHT BE TENSIONS WITH
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE YET
AMONG OTHER. COUNTRY LIKE THAT
REGARDLESS OF YOUR ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND I THINK YOU ARE THE
FIRST GENERATION LATINO I'M
WORTHY OF THE- NEVER GIVE UP ON
. THE COUCH HAS MADE IT POSSIBLE
ME TO CHOOSE THE AND MARK.
PROBLEM THE BLOCKER A ONE OF A
KIND OF. AND CLASS JOHN BY WHICH
IS ME TO FOR STRUCTURE INTO.
REALLY WITH MY PROFESSORS AND
ADMINISTRATORS. THE BILL HAS
ALREADY PRIDE IN MY ABILITY TO
PAY IT FORWARD AT SEVEN OUT OF
NETWORK OTHER QUESTION REASON
YOU DON'T. I AM VERY GRATEFUL
FOR MY TIME AT RUTLAND AND
DEFECATING. HAS GIVEN ME BOTH
ACADEMICALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
BEFORE YOU CALLED FOR BY TO
QUICKLY UNDERTAKEN. MY TALKING
TO WORK WITH BOTH SIDES. OF MY.
DEGREE AS AN OPPORTUNITY TALK
WITH MY- AND MY COMMUNITY PARKS
EACH. IS NOT. TO DEMONSTRATE THE
MORE BACKGROUND THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE ANYTHING EVEN MORE.
GROWING UP MY PARENTS ALWAYS AT
YOU. SOMETHING THAT TO TAKE AWAY
FROM. HOWEVER WHEN THE- BUT THE
ONE OF THE BUDGET WITH AWARD
AMOUNT TO BE. FROM YOUR YOUR-
YOUR THROUGH WHILE BUDGET ARE
LIKE FROM TO FIND WAYS TO FOR
THAT. THAT QUIET HERE TODAY I
THINK YOU NEED. FAVOR OF
ATHLETES ONE THE FUTURE OF THE
CAL EQUITABLE IN. AND
SUSTAINABLE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN YOUR RIGHT WHEN SHE THAT
EDGE NO ONE CAN IT AWAY YOU ARE
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO IN
SUPPORT. ON THE PHONE MODERATOR
CAN YOU LAY US KNOW IF WE HAVE
ANY. POSAR WE SHOULD CERTAINLY
FORTY TWO OR THREE I'M A LITTLE
RUSTY. FORTY TRUTH PLEASE YOUR
NAME AND I'D- FOR THE BILL. LAKE
MORNING CHAIR ALEX GRAVES WITH
THE ICC OF THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL JUST HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE
ANY. EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
WOULD LIKE THIS I SPEAK ON
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
ALLEN ATG APERTO CLIP WE GIVE
YOUR LIGHT NUMBER OFFLINE AND IN
PLACE RIGHT BACK IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE ARE
GETTING. PARTICIPANTS MY NUMBER.
M. OUR FIRST FIRST WILL BE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FORTY. FIND FORTY YOUR OPEN.HI MY
NAME IS GENERALLY AND I AM A
FORMER PROSECUTOR WHO. USUALLY
ATTENDED THE COLLEGE- THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN NEXT UP PROGRAM AND I
CURRENTLY WORK FOR A GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS PROGRAM THANK WITH
KNOWLEDGE IN CUBA DOES NOT HAVE
A NUMBER ON THE BILL. THIS OUT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU WE WILL BE
HEARING THAT BILL I BELIEVE AND
NEXT IF YOU COULD STAY ON THE
LINE. MISTER MODERATOR GO TO OUR
NEXT. COURT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY
WHAT'S GIVE ME SB EIGHT FIFTY
ONE. OKAY IF YOU ARE NOT
TESTIFYING FOR SB EIGHT FIFTY
ONE PLEASE- GO AHEAD AT ONE ZERO
TO TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF THE
QUEUE ORDER I TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB WOULD YOU SAY SIX
FIFTY ONE. EIGHT FIFTY ONE S. B.
EIGHT FIVE ONE. THANK YOU
MICHAEL WATER ALL THE GIANTS THE
COMPANY NUMBER THAT'S OKAY NOT
ONLY YOU SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK
WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS KATHLEEN
GARGANO WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURELY FROM ITS WILL ON OTHERS
ARE THEY- I'M LEARNING THIS
SOMEONE WILL. AND. ON BEHALF. SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. I LOVE MISTER
. CHALLENGES I STARTED ACT TRIAL
AND BLANQUART ARLEDGE WHERE MY-
EIGHT WELL YOU KNOW ZERO. AND
THEN I. THINK AM ARE INCIDENT OF
THE BILL. I AM PERFECT THANK
CANNOT RETURN COLLEGE. THANK YOU
WILL GO ONLINE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. THIS IS A INTERNET MAILING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO AND WE
WANT TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR
S. B. EIGHT FIVE ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
WILL OUTLINE TWENTY SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. BY MANY MECHANIC
FRANCO I'M AS DETECTED AT USC-
LINE AT THE PORT OF AT THE EIGHT
FIFTY ONE TERRIFIC THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. AISLEYNE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS VERONICA I AM AT THE
MERIDEN CALLER AT BY THE PCP
CALLING THE CORE OF AT EIGHT
ONE. AM. NEXT CALLER AND MOVING
A LOT. THANK YOU MISS BENNET
SURE WE'LL GO TO LINE- FORTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DR JOY CARE PRESIDENT OF
LAPIERRE UNIVERSITY AND I'D LIKE
TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT FIVE ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE
FORTY PLEASE ON MUTE NOT THEY
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT TO KILL- AND
THE FINAL REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT FIVE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
MADAM CHAIR TERRIFIC THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL.
I SEE NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE- STANDING IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN A POSITION TO S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY ONE PLUS. AND TO TEST
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT FIVE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP PROPOSITION AT THIS
TIME MADAM CHAIR GREAT THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR ALRIGHT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER CORTESE SIR
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND I NOTICED THAT THE- MAJORITY
LEADER EMERITUS IS JOINED US SO
THERE'S THREE OF US IN THIS ROOM
WITH THE CONNECTION TO THE
UNIVERSITY. REDLANDS SO WERE
OVERWHELMING THIS HEARING ROOM-
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE STUDENTS. AND
ADMINISTRATORS TODAY IT AFFECTS
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN A VERY
POSITIVE WAY AND IT AFFECTS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO NEED OUR HELP
SERVE OUR HELP. AND WE- BACK.
AMEND CAL GRANT JUST THAT CENTER
PORTANTINO WE ARE STILL
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER CORTESE I
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
MOVE ON FOR SECOND AUTHORS
SENATORS LAYERED WITH BE EIGHT I
HAVE SEVEN- PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING- 2% SENATE
BILL EIGHT EIGHT FIVE ON FOSTER
USE AND I REALLY FIRST OUT THE
GATE- REALLY WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK AND THEIR COLLABORATION ON
THIS LEGISLATION. THIS ILL
SEEKS TO EXPAND THE SERVICES
THAT ARE DELIVERED- TO CURRENT
FOSTER YOUTH ACROSS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THERE IS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM AND THIS FORMALLY NAMES
IT NEXT UP IS KNOWN BY. NOW
WHICH PROVIDES FORMER AND
CURRENT FOSTER STUDENTS FROM
DIFFERENT SUPPORTS INCLUDING
COUNSELING BOOK AND SUPPLY
GRANTS TO DRINK CARTONS CHAU
PERSISTENCE HEALTH SERVICES
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND OF OTHER
SUPPORT OF STRESSES. AS THIS WAS
A MAJOR REGIONALLY ENACTED IT
LIMITS THE PROGRAM TO TWENTY
CAMPUSES OF THE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN OR DISTRICTS IN THE SYSTEM
THIS ELIMINATES THE CAP THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOMMENDED SOME
MORE MONEY. FOR THE PROGRAM IN
THIS BUDGET. AND THEY'RE ALL SO
SOME OTHER CHANGES IN THE
PROGRAM MADE BUT THAT'S THE
MAJOR PIECE OF IT AND- I WANT TO
ADDRESS ONE POINT BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT A COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO IS
NOT HERE YET. PROSJE TO ME ABOUT
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS TAKING
UNDER NINE UNITS WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THEY WOULD
STILL HAVE THE PLAN THAT MOVES
THEM AND RIGHT NOW THERE SOME
STUDENTS THAT ARE ONE CLASS
SHORT AND THERE THERE. ARE AND
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY TO MORE
UNITS BUT THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
TAKE TO SUPPORT SERVICES ARE
PARTICIPATING. THIS GIVES.
STATUTORY FLEXIBILITY TO INCLUDE
PEOPLE AND ALLOW THEM TO DO IT.
THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION AND
THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IS
TO BE RAPTURED DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FROM THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND KAREN
LOPEZ TO CREATE A CURRENT UC
BERKELEY STUDENT FORMER
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE NEXT UP
AND ROLLED STUDENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPOD
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED AND
BEFORE WE MOVE TO YOUR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS LABOR. HERE PHOTO ABOVE
RETURNABLE HERE COURTESY CURTIS
HERE DELHI DELHI HERE GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN AM HERE ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU MADAM
CONSULTANT ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO ALL YOUR LEAD SUPPORT
CENTER LAYERED LET'S START WITH
THE STUDENT- KAREN LOPEZ PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS KAREN LOPEZ AND
I RECENTLY GRADUATED FROM
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE AND I AM
A FORMER BOSS YOU. LIKE MANY
LAWSUIT DURING MY TIME IN FOSTER
CARE AT THESE EDUCATIONAL
SECURITY. GOLD SIX TIMES WHICH
PREVENTED ME FROM FEELING ENGAGE
IN MY EDUCATION. READ A LACK OF
INTEREST IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND
LIFE AFTER HIGH SCHOOL I ALSO
LIKE EDUCATIONAL GARDENS IN
OVERALL BASIC NEED SUPPORT. I
WAS GREETED BY IN HIGH SCHOOL I
HESITANTLY APPLY TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AFTER GRADUATING. MY
INITIAL EXPERIENCE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WAS NOT THE BEST I DID
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
FINANCIAL AID AND THE PROCESS TO
APPLY. I THOUGHT LASSEN
UNDERSTANDING BASIC COLLEGE
TERMINOLOGY AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE. IT WASN'T UNTIL I WAS
CONNECTED WITH LAWSUIT SUPPORT
PROGRAMS LIKE NEXT UP. THAT
TRANSFORM INTO YOUR DREAM
COLLEGE FOR THE PAST. THE
PROVIDED A VAST AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT ALLOWED ME TOOK
SOME COURSES AND EXTRACURRICULAR
. IT PROVIDED FOR A TRULY NEEDED
TO GROW AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND AS
A STUDENT. TO HELP MOVE HOUSING
RESOURCES WHEN I WAS HOMELESS
AND WORKED THREE JOBS. THEY GOT
SOME GOOD STATE AND HELP COVERED
MY BASIC NEEDS WHILE AT RCC. THE
FACT THAT STAFF MEMBERS CREATED
OR CATER TOWARDS VASHI
COMMUNITIES WHEN WE FEEL
UNDERSTOOD DURING THE ACADEMIC
GOOD NUMBERS. THERE SUPPORT HELP
ME FIND A TRUE PASSION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. NEXT THE POUNDS OR
SOMETHING WITH THE TRANSFER
PROCESS. AND MAJOR WORK ON THE
RIGHT PATH. IT WAS WITH THEIR
AND- SUPPORT ME GET X. TO THE
ALL BE. IN THE UC SYSTEM. WHICH
I NOW ATTEND UC BERKELEY ON THE
WHOLE RIGHT. NEXT DOOR TO
PASSION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT I WOULD NOT
BE IN COLLEGE IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE SUPPORT DURING MY TIME AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I BELIEVE
ALTHOUGH SHE SHOULD HAVE SHOULD
HAVE. ACCESS TO THE SERVICES
WHICH IS WHY I'M INCLUDES THE
COURT OF SB EIGHT FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. MS
WASHER BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
PLEASE. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
ASSEMBLY KAREN'S EXPERIENCE TO
FOSTER CARE IS NOT UNIQUE
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS INDICATOR SHOWS THAT
ONLY 13% OF SAUCIER REPAIRS FOR
COLLEGE AND CAREERS COMPARED
2402% OF ALL STUDENTS. THIS LACK
OF ACADEMIC PREPAREDNESS ALONG
WITH HISTORY OF TRAUMA LACK OF
FAMILY SUPPORT IN HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS POINT TO THE NEED
FOR THIS TYPE OF SPECIALIZED AND
TARGETED SUPPORT. HI CARE AND
HAVE PROVEN THAT DESPITE THESE
BARRIERS WHICH SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS CAN BE SUCCESSFUL. AS
EXPERIENCE ALSO POINTS TO THE
NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY RELATED TO
MINIMUM UNIT REQUIREMENTS AS
PROPOSED BY S. B. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. SIX DURING HOMELESSNESS
AND WORKING THREE JOBS AS KAREN
DESCRIBING HER TESTIMONY IT'S
NOT UNUSUAL FOR SHALL SEE. AN
EXTRA PROGRAM SHOULD HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET STUDENTS
WHERE THEY'RE AT TO MAXIMIZE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE.
PUT PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING NOT A GREAT FAN TOO
MANY COSTLY A CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S JOHNSON
PRASAD THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATORS FOR THIS INCENTIVE
FOR CALIFORNIA CAN YOU COLLEGES
AND WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS AND THEN TRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE MORNING TARGETING
BY SURE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS IN
TRANSIT AFFAIRS OFFICER FOR THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR. AND
BRING UP ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. MADAM
CHAIR SAID IF YOU I WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT EIGHT TYPE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. OTHER
WAYS WAIT UNTIL YOUR BILL IS UP
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH A LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. WHAT
ABOUT THE FIND CAÑADA CAMPUS
YOUR BILL COLLEGE LOCATED IN
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA. HANK YOU
FOR SB EIGHTY FIVE. AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT THREE HUNDRED SELF
IDENTIFIED FOX YOU. CAN GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM MAX THAT PROGRAM
MAXIMIZE THE SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NECKLINE SIX PLEASE CALL. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DANIELLE ONE
DRUG WITH CHILDREN NOW CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. PINE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JAN NINE MERLIN I AM
A FORMER BOSS YOU KNOW WHAT THE
STUDENT AT COLLEGE THAT DIDN'T
HAVE AN EXTRA PROGRAM AND I
CURRENTLY WORK FOR A GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS STREET CORNER I THANK
THE COLLEGE THAT DOESN'T HAVE AN
ACCENT COLOR BROWN. I AM A
PARTNER THE CARD THANK YOU. YEAH
AND NEXT WEEK WILL GO TO THIRTY
TWO YEAR ARE OPEN. THIRTY TWO
PLEASE ON MUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXIS YEAH I'M AT A COLLEGE AT
THE PORT OF SPD FIGHT I'M TO
EXPECT MIX OF PROGRAMS TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I NEED.
TRANSPORT MANY BY THE FEW
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE WILL GO TO LINE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING BECAUSE
JORDAN CENTER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IS CONNECTION.
SPONSORED FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
CALLING SUPPORT FOR X. EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU. HAVING A LONG
LINE THIRTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS DORA LOZANO
FOSTER YOUTH COUNSELOR AT
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS AND I
SUPPORT SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. BY FORTY EIGHT YOUR
UP. HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
ATORES AND I AM A FORMER BUSH
YOU I CURRENTLY GO TO
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE.
THANK YOU. I THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GLORIA MARTINEZ I AM
CURRENTLY A BOXING. AMETEK
COLLEGE AND BECAUSE THE PARENTS
DIDN'T WORK ON THE NEXT STEP
PROGRAM AND I AM IN SUPPORT SB
EIGHT I. THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
FIVE- YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ALEXIS A FORMER STUDENT AND
COST YOU SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
HERE IN FULL SUPPORT SB EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING JUSTIN SILICON
BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION YET BUT WILL BE TAKING
A SUPPORT POSITION LATER THIS
MONTH AND WANTED TO THINK THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL AND THEIR EFFORTS IN THE-
BUDGET. ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ERICA KEY WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WEARING STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY
NINETEEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIANA
RICHIE AND I'M DEPARTING DOLLARS
PROGRAM COORDINATOR ACTIVE REAL
COLLEGE I AM INSURING THE POOR
S. B. EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANKS
AND PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS CODY I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I GRADUATED FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AT CONSUMES RIVER
COLLEGE I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MY
NAME'S MACKENZIE GREEN I'M NOT
COLUMBIA COLLEGE FOSTER STUDENT
COUNSELOR AND A FOSTER PARENT
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. M. LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LIMON A FORMER-
ARAMBULA. COLLEGE NINE- WAY TO
YOU. THANK YOU. BRING ONLINE
FIFTY YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FEATURED AFFECT THE
NUMBER OF COLLEGE SUPPORT OF
BILLS EIGHT EIGHT I. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WITH THAT
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO YOU FOR
ANYONE. WHO'S CALLING INTO
OPPOSE SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. I
WOULD LIKE TO I TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE END UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SEEING NONE CERTAINLY IT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST THANK
EVERYBODY THIRD START TESTIFIED
NOT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU SENATOR. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY MADAM SEX MADAM
CONSULTED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI OTOBO I WOULD
TROUBLED BY CORTESE HI WHATEVER
THE AYE DALY. KELLY I GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN HI. THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES GET OUT
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR.
LET'S GO BACK TO S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY ONE NOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM THE BILL WAS MOVED BY
SENATOR CORTESE MENTAL
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB. EIGHT
FIFTY ONE THE MOTION. RE REFER
THE CAN ON APPROPRIATION. LEYVA
HI LEYVA HI- TROUBLED BY VIRTUAL
BURBANK TENNESSEE. COURTESY I'D
- DALLI UGLY. AYE PLEASE AYE
MCGUIRE. PAN HI AND I. THE BILL
ALSO THE NUMBER WE'LL LEAVE IT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE ALL
RIGHT OUR NEXT- AUTHOR IS CENTER
BAKER BUT HE IS NOT HERE. I DO
SEE CENTER HERTZBERG CENTER
HERTZBERG IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT COME RIGHT UP ALL RIGHT
CENTER HERTZBERG IS PRESENTING
ON SB NINE THIRTEEN. AND YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU ARE WELCOME. TO MAKE
THINGS. YEAH THE. THANK YOU
VENTURE MEMBERS TWENTY MESSED
CONFIDENT YOU'RE JUST FINE. SO
ON. THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IS THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE
SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT A
COUNTRY THERE'S BEEN A SERIES OF
STEP BY THE EXEMPTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO- THIS SIZE OF A
DISTRICT OVER THE YEARS AND
BECAUSE- OF THE PANDEMIC THE CAP
NOW IS FOR ITS IS A FOUR
THOUSAND WE WANT TO REDUCE IT TO
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND. SO THAT-
WE AVOID SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE ARE FACING WITH RESPECT
TO L. A. U. S. T. AGAIN AS I SAY
THE ROMANS DOWN JUST LAST YEAR
ALONE BY TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND SO I'VE GOT A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES HERE BUT
THIS BILL IS A THREE QUEST OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT- AND MAKING
THIS STATUTORY CHANGED BECAUSE
OF A- CHANGE IN CIRCUMSTANCES TO
THE- PANDEMIC. I HAVE EVER
BATISTA'S OF ALLAH WHO'S HERE
AND ALSO ALEXANDER ABLE LINO
WITH THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S TESTIFIED ON
BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER HERTZBERG-
WE WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT
STARTING WITH- DEBRA BUT HE'S TO
THE BALL YOU AVE TWO MINUTES
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ALEXANDER MOLINA. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISS OF ALL
OUT. WAR GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
CHARLIE THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF MY NAME IS
THAT WHAT ABOUT THE STATE OF
IOWA AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. FOR THE LAST TWO
DECADES LOS ANGELES UNIFIED HAS
BEEN EXPERIENCING A TREND O
DECLINING STUDENT ENROLLMENT.
MOSTLY DUE TO DECLINING BIRTH
RATES HOUSING UNAFFORDABILITY
AND MIGRATION OF RESIDENTS OUT
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY. IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR ALONE. COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
EXPERIENCE A LOSS OF TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS. OR 6%
OF OUR TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION
. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED RISKS
FALLING UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND EIGHTY EIGHT AND WILL
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO OPERATE
UNDER THE EXISTING LAWS
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZE FOR LEDS
WITH FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE MORE. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED VIEWS THESE PROVISIONS
OF SB NINE THIRTEEN S. TECHNICAL
CHANGES BY LOWERING THE EIGHTY
EIGHT THRESHOLD 230-010-0080
EIGHT. AND WILL ALLOW THE
DISTRICT TO CONTINUE TO UTILIZE
STATUTORY PROVISIONS PERTAINING
TO THE GOVERNANCE AND OPERATIONS
OF OUR SCHOOLS. OF WHICH WE HAVE
BEEN OPERATING UNDER FOR
DECADES. AT THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
SECOND LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE COLONIES OF SCALE THAT
JUSTIFY MAINTAINING CURRENT
PROVISIONS FOR THESE REASONS THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS SPONSORING SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTEEN. ENERGIZED BY
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I BELIEVE MISTER
MOLINA IS HERE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ONLY SO WE WILL GO TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK ON SB NINE THIRTEEN
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT PLEASE
PROCEED. SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
THIRTEEN. ONCE AGAIN THE
REGISTER SUPPORT PRESS THREE
NINE THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. I'M SURE WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL IS THERE ANYONE OF
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WISHESTO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
EIGHT NINE THIRTEEN. SEEING NONE
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO YOU
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE SB
NINE THIRTEEN. REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION PRESS THREE NINE
THIRTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE.
YOUR MANAGER KNOWNAS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR PAM. YES
ENTERED ROAD THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD DO
YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW WHAT'S THE
SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT'S THE NUMBER
OF ITEMS I DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY BUT GIVEN THE ASKER
I WOULD SUGGEST IS PROBABLY
SACRAMENTO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I ACTUALLY I THINK
YOUR WITNESS KNOWS GO AHEAD AND
GET A GOOD UNIFIED WITH JUST
UNDER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EIGHTY EIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO I
JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW FAR THE
THRESHOLD IS BUT THAT I I'M I'LL
BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER PANTS AND A DOLLY. I
JUST WANTED TO. DO SO THAT'S OF
SEEMS LIKE A LOT. BUT THE
NUMBER. FOR ONE YEAR- WAS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND I THINK THAT USE.
MENTIONED DUE TO THOSE TO THOSE
STUDENTS. DID THEY GO TO
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS OR TODAY-
LEAVE OUR STATE OR DO YOU KNOW
DO YOU HAVE ABILITY TO KNOW
WHERE THEY WENT. OUR RECORDS
INDICATE THAT DUE TO DECLINING
BIRTH RATES UNAFFORDABILITY OF
HOUSING. AND STUDENTS WHO ARE
TRANSFERRING TO OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR OUT OF THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES ARE THE RATIONALE
FOR THE DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT.
FEE I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DATA WHICH SHOWS BEYOND OUTSIDE
THE COUNTY WHAT THIS CASE. THANK
YOU SENATE DOLLY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE SEEING NONE OF CENTER
PROJECT CLOSELY JUST VERY
BRIEFLY YOU KNOW WE MAKE THESE
ASSUMPTIONS IN THE LAW. WHEN
THIS LAW WAS WRITTEN AT A FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR THOUSAND
HUGE SCHOOL DISTRICT COMPARED TO
THE ONE I THINK IT'S ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND- IN THE COUNTY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND NO ONE WOULD
HAVE ASSUMED THAT COULD BE FOUR
THOUSAND WAS THE NUMBER THAT
WORKS SO YOU KNOW PICKING THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS THAT THE
NUMBER SHOULD BE THREE FIFTY WE
DON'T KNOW BUT THE IDEA IS TO
GIVE ROOM WITHIN THE LAW. SO
THAT THESE SPECIAL PROVISIONS
ARE REALLY DEALING WITH GIGANTIC
DISTRICTS AND AT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IT'S STILL A JACKET THE
DISTRICT WITH THAT AS FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SAID HERTZBERG
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAM. BEEN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER. SB NINE THIRTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
OTOBO. AYE PHOTOBOOK AYE
COURTESY AYE. FURTIVELY AYE
DALLI. DALLI AYE GLAZER. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. PAN BY AND I. THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR HERTZBERG. ALL
RIGHT OF CENTER BAKER IS NOT
HERE. US SENATOR BANT PAN YOU
HAVE A BILL TO PRESENT FOR
YOURSELF. AND ALSO FOR CENTER
LIMÓN WHICH LIKE TO PRESENT FROM
HERE OR YOU MAY GO TO THE PODIUM
YOUR CHOICE. TORONTO JUST.
PRESENT HERE THAT WAS GREAT OKAY
WE'RE GONNA START WITH S. B.
NINE OH EIGHT- BYE CENTER PANTS
CENTER PAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. HI FOR THAT TO YOU
SENATE BILL NINE OH EIGHT WHICH
IS A MEASURE CREATED BY STUDENTS
TO UP LIFT OTHER STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY SB. NINE OH EIGHT
WILL INCREASE STUDENT
REPRESENTATION. AT CALIFORNIA OF
IT VICE. A THIRD PERSON YOUTH
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. UNDER THE
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER ON THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO NEARLY SIX MILLION
STUDENTS AND ALL OF THEM HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES
PERSPECTIVES THAT CAN IMPROVE
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM. HOWEVER
ONLY ONE STUDENTIS CURRENTLY
REPRESENTING ALL SIX MILLION
STUDENTS ON THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF EDUCATION. AND THE ONE
STUDENTS SIMPLY CANNOT
ADEQUATELY REPRESENT ALL THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS.
AND THAT'S WHY THE COMMISSION
UNDERSTOOD THE STATE WAS UNDER
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS COME FROM EVERY REGION
OF THE STATE TEN ARE SELECTED
BASED ON THEIR PASSION
EXPERIENCE. RATHER NO GRADES
THIS WILL ALLOW THE COMMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A ROCK BROAD RANGE
OF ISSUES. AFFECTING THEM
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH GUN
VIOLENCE PULLING IN OTHER TYPES
OF ISSUES. NOW MORE THAN EVER IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ELEVATE
VOICES OF STUDENTS THROUGH SB
NINE AWAIT SO WE CAN EMPOWER
THEM TO SOLVE ISSUES MOST
IMPORTANT THEM. JOINING ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- CATHERINE
CHU AND MEAN A LEAD OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH CENTER PAN ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES WE'LL
START WITH CATHERINE SHU AND
THEN MOVE ON TO MEAN THE LEE.
AND HOW NICE THAT YOU'RE YOU
COULDN'T TESTIFY RIGHT THERE
FROM. THE MICROPHONE IT'S GREAT
TO SEE PEOPLE HERE TESTIFYING IN
PERSON. PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THE MORNING CARE LEYVA AND
SAID EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KATHERINE SHOE AND
I'M A SENIOR AT WESLEY HIGH
SCHOOL IN THE CANAL VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS AS OUR
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS POLICY
DIRECTOR TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
SUPPORT AND SPONSORING AS BEING
ON A WAY. TO BRING FRUIT BRIEFLY
REITERATE THE BILL SB NINE AWAIT
TREATMENT A SENIOR ADVISER
COMMISSION UNDER THE STATE'S YOU
TO BOARD MEMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF EDUCATION
THIS YOU DON'T REMEMBER POSITION
WAS ESTABLISHED TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO HAVE A VOICE IN
EDUCATION DECISIONS IT'S A GREAT
WAY FOR NEEDS TO BE HEARD AT THE
STATE LEVEL. HOWEVER CURRENTLY
THIS ONE MEMBERS TASKED TO
REPRESENT THE SIX POINT THREE
MILLION STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
FROM WHAT THIS POSITION WAS
FIRST ESTABLISHED TO OUR
POPULATION NOW IT IS A HUGE TASK
TO TRULY REPRESENT THE SHEER
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS WITH NO
FORMAL STRUCTURE IN PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THIS CAN LEAD TO THE
MISREPRESENTATION OF STUDENTS
AND OUR STATE. ESPECIALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED WINDS. AND PAST
MOST STATES BERMAN HAVE FROM.
URBAN AREA LIKE THE AREA OR LOS
ANGELES. VOICES FROM AREAS LIKE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE NOT BEEN
ADEQUATELY REPRESENTED. WHICH
CAN SKEW THE ACCURACY OF WHAT
THE STUDENT BOARD MEMBER SHARES
WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. LAST YEAR WHEN I WAS
RUNNING FOR THIS YOU NUMBER
MEMBER POSITION ALONGSIDE ELEVEN
OTHER SEMI FINALISTS. WE
UNANIMOUSLY AGREE THAT ISSUE
NUMBER AS OUR COMMISSION IS
ESSENTIAL. AFTER ALL MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS AND STUDENT
ADVISORY COUNCILS. SO IT WOULD
ONLY MAKE SENSE OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION WHICH MAKES
ASSERTIONS FOR MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE ONE AS WELL.
I A RESULT THE STUDENT ADVISORY
COMMISSION PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
WOULD BE COMPOSED OF STUDENTS
FROM TWELVE REGIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR
DIVERSE REPRESENTATION IN THE
STRUCTURE THAT WE HOPE. COULD
LAST FOR MANY YEARS. THESE
PERSPECTIVES WILL BETTER INFORM
THE STATE'S YOU KNOW BOARD
MEMBER. AND UPDATES CAN BE
RELATED TO THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AS WELL. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN FOR EMPOWERING YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
CONVERSATION AND UNDERSTANDING
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUTH. VOICES
IN EDUCATION DECISIONS I THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE FOR
ON SB NINE AWAIT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEENA LEAVE PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
AS THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE MY
NAME IS MERELY A CURRENT SENIOR
AT JOHN MARSHALL HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES I'M HERE TODAY I SEE
SOME STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. TO DEMONSTRATE
CAST SUPPORT FOR NETFLIX SB NINE
AWAIT. I THINK STUDENT WHO GREW
UP IN THE LARGEST DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE SECOND
LARGEST IN THE NATION. I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA HOT ONE
THOUSAND AND THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I'M SURE YOU CAN
IMAGINE MY SURPRISE WHEN I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT OTHER DISTRICTS FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS AGO I TO CAST
CONFERENCE. I ALSO DIDN'T KNOW
THAT STUDENTS COULD BE THE
DECISION MAKERS BY RUNNING FOR
SB IMPOSITIONS IT WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICT. AND ON A STATEWIDE
LEVEL. THE IDEA THAT A FELLOW
STUDENT WITH GETTING MY VOICE
HEARD ON A PROBLEM LARGER THAN I
EVER IMAGINED. MAYES THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD YOU KNOW. QUESTION
STARTED TO ARISE HOWEVER WHEN I
HEARD THAT THERE WAS ONLY ONE
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER. MAKING
THESE DECISIONS ON THE BEHALF OF
SIX POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS. HOW CAN A
STUDENT FROM SAN DIEGO PROPERLY
REPRESENTATIVE AND VOICE THE
VASTLY DIFFERENT STRUGGLES THAT
LEAVES THE STUDENTS FEES. EVERY
STUDENT AND EVERY REGION
DESERVES TO BE HEARD ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL AND THAT IS WHAT
SB NINE AWAIT ACHIEVES.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH DONE BY
UCLA THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. WHAT'S NEXT IN
ITS MAKE UP 70% OF THIS COMP
POPULATION ALL BLACK STUDENTS
MAKE UP 9% A STARK CONTRAST IN
COMPARISON TO TURNED AND ROLLED
MATT NUMBERS. ANOTHER STUDY DONE
BY UCLA SHOW THAT 10% OF
STUDENTS PUBLICLY IDENTIFIED AS
A PART OF THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. HE'S A QUESTION AGAIN
HOW CAN ONE STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER. ADEQUATE REPRESENT THE
DIVERSE AND GROWING SIX POINT
THREE MILLION STUDENT POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA. IMPLEMENTING A
13% BY THREE COUNCIL WILL NOT
ONLY ENSURE THAT STUDENTS FROM
MULTIPLE REGIONS ARE REPRESENTED
DIRECTLY ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL TO
THE STATE STUDENT BOARD MEMBER.
IT WIL ALSO SHOW OUR STUDENTS
THAT THEIR VOICE MATTERS AND
THAT THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD TO
CREATE CHANGE TO MAKE SCHOOL
SAFE PLACE A PLACE TO LOOK FOR
TO GOING EVERYDAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU MISLI. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO IN THE SUPPORT HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO STATE THEIR NAME AND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL MAY DO SO.
SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES FOR S. B. NINE ZERO EIGHT
. REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT FOR S.
B. NINE ZERO EIGHT FOR EXPENSE
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME- ONCE
AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR NINE ZERO EIGHT- I'M
SURE NO ONE HAS KICKED UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY AGAINST SB NINE OH EIGHT
SEEING THAT MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
ASK ON OUR PHONE LINES IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
NINE ZERO. EIGHT BUT TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION TO NINE ZERO EIGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE AT THIS
TIME. AND. ONCE AGAIN I'M SURE
WE HAVE NOBODY CAN THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR ARE IT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
SENATOR GLAZERS. BUT TEXTURE
LEYVA AYE WHEN I. CERTAINLY
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD THANK YOU
STUDENTS THAT ARE HERE TO
REPRESENT- AND THEY DID DID IT
SO WELL- DOT. EIGHT TAKE THINK
TOO FAR BACK IN YOUR PAST BUT I
THINK I WAS A CAST-
REPRESENTATIVE FROM MY HIGH
SCHOOL BACK IN THE DAY. AND I SO
APPRECIATE THAT ABILITY TO
CONNECT. WITH THE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM AND HAVE HONEST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING IN THE SCHOOL ROOM-
IT'S- IT'S NOW IS A GOOD FOR THE
INPUT SIDE BUT IT ALSO REALLY.
IS GREAT FOR THE LEADERSHIP SIDE
THAT I CERTAINLY EXPERIENCED.
FIVE LEGISLATION- THAT'S PENDING
BEFORE THE SENATE HOPING TO HAVE
IT COME I THINK TO THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT WOULD ALLOW
SCHOOL BOARDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
VOTING STUDENT MEMBER. VOTING
STUDENT MEMBER ON THEIR BOARDS
IF THEY SO CHOOSE TO TAKE THAT
TAKE THAT POSITIVE STEP. ALSO
THAT LEGISLATION THAT DID PASS
THE SENATE THIS YEAR THAT WOULD
ADD A SECOND VOTING STUDENT ON
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. SO THIS
IDEA OF STUDENT CONNECTION THAT
REPRESENTATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
I HOPE THAT- CONFIDENT THIS BILL
CAN MOVE FORWARD OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SEEING NONE CENTER PAM
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS FOR BRENDA FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND I
WANTED MY TWO WITNESSES FOR
COMING HERE IN PERSON TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT CAPTIONS NOT SHOOT.
PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING HERE EXPERTLY US WHEN I
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER PAN
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GLAZER MENTAL CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. NINE ZERO
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS. BUT
FIRST A- ME AS A MAN BUT FOR.
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS ONE MOMENT PLEASE
. I MEAN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE NO
PROBLEM-
AND- MY APOLOGIES THE MOTION IS
DUE TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
CENTER LEYVA HI LEYVA HI PATROL
BOAT I THE TROUBLED BY COURTESY
HI COURTESY I DELI DELI I GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN AM I
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES GET APPLE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
UNDER BILL BECKER WELCOME YOU'RE
HERE TO PRESENT SB. EIGHT NINETY
THREE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MANAGER. HAPPY
FIRST OF HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK. ON THIS BILL.
THIS BILL MCKINNEY COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS MST IN
NEEDS WITHIN THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. ALSO REFERRED AS S. M.
C. C. C. D. WHICH IS EASIER. TO
MAKE COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BARRIERS
TO ATTEND COLLEGE INCLUDING
ROAMING FEES BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING FOOD AND
OTHER COSTS THAT COME OUT TO
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND. DOLLARS
EIGHT STUDENTS IN THE PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. FLEXIBILITY IS
REQUESTED NEEDED BY S. M. CCD
SECOND BETTER UTILIZE EXISTING
LOCAL REVENUE TO REMOVE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS.
AND TO SUPPORT THEM WITH THE
TOTAL COST OF A DENSE. WITH THIS
BILL WILL EMPOWER THE CEMETERY
CAN COLLEGES TO PROVIDE AND
EXPAND THEIR GLOBAL ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
MARGINALIZED AND
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT
POPULATIONS. AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO DEMONSTRATE FINANCIAL NEED.
THANKS AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ESTIMATED FOUR
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL STUDENTS ON
TOP OF THE TWO THOUSAND ALREADY
SERVED ON THE CURRENT PROMISE
SCHOLARS. PROGRAM WITHOUT ANY
ADDED COSTS TO THE STATE YOU MAY
REMEMBER THIS BILL FROM LAST
YEAR WE CAME BACK MINISTRY
FOCUSED. NOW ON THIS COUNTY IT
PROVIDES THAT THE SCHOOLS WITH
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO USE THEIR
EXISTING FUNDS EXISTING LOCAL
REVENUE THAT'S ISSUE HERE. TO
REDUCE OR WAIVE STUDENT FEES AND
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. TO OFFSET THE COST OF
FOOD TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED BEING A STUDENT. IN
DOING SO THIS GIVES SEMATECH IN
COLLEGE THE TOOL TO REMOVE
BARRIERS THERE KEEPING STUDENTS
FROM ROLLING OR COMPLETING THEIR
DEGREES. WITH ME TODAY TESTIFY
OR DOCTOR ERIN MCKEAN BY CHANCER
FOR EDUCATIONAL SERVICE AND
PLANNING. AT THE PENTECOSTAL
CHURCH. AND PREACHER TRUCK TO IS
A PERFORMER PROMISE SCHOLAR
STUDENT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THANK YOU AS PER CLASS
FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR BAKER ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH YOUR LEAD
WITNESS DR ERIN. MCKEAN PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY- THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING TO LEYVA
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. IS HONOR
SPEECHES TODAY SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY TREATMENTS
UNDER BACKER. MY NAME IS DR ONLY
BEING AND I AM THE VICE
CHANCELLOR OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES AND PLANNING FOR THE
TENTATIVE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. SB A NINETY
THREE MAKES TO SMALL BUT
CRITICAL CHANGES THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE SAME THEIR COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
USE LOCAL RESOURCES TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO HIGHER. EDUCATION IN
PART THE SUPPLEMENT AB NINETEEN
FUNDS TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE PART OF OUR
PROMISE SCHOLARS PROGRAM. AT ALL
COULD YOU CAN BOARD STUDENTS
BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND FAMILY CARE.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL OUR LOCAL
BOARD OF TRUSTEES TO ADOPT
POLICIES THAT REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE A ROMAN FEES FOR
STUDENTS BASED ON CRITERIA SUCH
AS DOCUMENTED FINANCIAL NEEDS.
AND TO DEDICATE LOCAL RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
A TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE. BOTH
OF THESE CHANGES WERE ALLOW OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
BUILD ON EXISTING PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE BUDGET THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT AND AB.
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE. I RECENTLY OUT WHAT
MIGHT BE CHANGES WILL LIKE IN.
THE BILL OR LOCAL BOARD OF. WILL
BE REQUIRED TO ADOPT LOCAL
POLICY. THESE COULD AFFORD.
EXPANDED CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE GRANT PROGRAMS SERVE
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT CURRENTLY
QUALIFY. BUT NONE THE LESS HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED. HEARING SAM
DETAIL COUNTY THE MEDIAN SINGLE
FAMILY HOME PRICE IS MORE THAN
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. WELL WE
HAVE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT BENEFIT FROM THOSE
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES. THE
INCREDIBLY HIGH COST OF LIVING
INCREASE A TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL
BARRIER TO THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE HOW SUCH WE CAN EXPAND OUR
ABILITY FOR FEE WAIVERS TO TWO
HUNDRED OR EVEN THREE HUNDRED
PERCENT. OF THE CURRENT
pINCOME LEVELS AND IT'S A BENEFIT
FAMILIES AND DAMAGING- COUNTY
THAT ARE BARELY ABLE TO MEET AND
MEET. AND YET DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS. THESE ARE
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND FOR US
IN THE COUNTY AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. THIS IS AN
EQUITY ISSUE. NOT ONLY CAN ARE
WAIT AND ELIMINATE THAT BURIED
TO ATTENDING. BUT ALSO. OUR
DOLLARS PRO. WHICH IS OUR LOCAL
CALL FROM PROGRAM. BY PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE YES INCLUDES BOOKS
FOOD SECURITY TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER BASIC NEEDS. ALLOWING US
TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT IN THIS
COMPLETION FOCUSED. DOESN'T MORE
THAN DOUBLED TWO AND THREE YEAR
GRADUATION RATES ARE DISTRICT
ALREADY. WE CURRENTLY SERVE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS
EVERY YEAR BUT SB EIGHT NINETY
THREE WOULD ALLOW US TO MEET THE
DEMAND TO SERVICE ME AT SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. THERE IS NO
BETTER JIM GREW THE LIVES OF
STUDENTS THEIR FAMILIES AND THE
COMMUNITY THEY LIVE IN. AND THE
ECONOMY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT TO GET STUDENTS
TO COMPLETE A COLLEGE DEGREE.
FOR ALL THESE REASONS OUR
DISTRICTS SUPPORT SB NINETY
THREE. RIGHT NOW LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO ONE OF OUR PROMISE
SCHOLAR GRADUATES COLLEGE A DROP
SHARE WITH YOU THE IMPACT THIS
BERMAN AT. LIFE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.
PERFECT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. AND DR GRANT. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS. COMMITTEE THIS
CALL. ARE AND I CAN TO CALL THIS
. CARE FROM NINETEEN POINT
TWENTY ONE. THE NUMBER OF THE
PROBLEM FOLLICLE. I STILL DO NOT
THE PROMISE. PROBE SHOULD BE YOU
DIDN'T GET. IN MY LIFE. IT IS
SOMETHING YOU NEVER BE TAKING
GRANTED. I AM THE BEST
EXPERIENCE ON THE OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL. IN GOING TO FALL
MARCHING. RIGHT OFF THE FRONT
LINE I WAS SO MANY CARD SO TO
SPEAK. ATTENDING FIFTH SAM UNDER
THE PROP ALMOST FOR WITH MY
OPPORTUNITY A SECOND CHANCE.
ASSEMBLY WAS EIGHTY NINE STATES
AROUND AND ATTACK. BUNDLE FOR
THE OPERATING UNDER A FOR WE
CERTAINLY DO NOT LEAVE LAW. A
LITTLE ATTENTION BECAUSE WAS
INCREDIBLE. HELPS NOVEL ON SHE
FINANCIAL.
HEARTLESS ARBUCKLE THE SCHOLARS
PROGRAM THE TREASURY FROM
MULTIMEDIA COUNSELORS TO
WORKSHOPS ON HOW TO START A
MAJOR ARTICLE NOT A RESUME.
CONTROL NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES
AND MUCH MUCH MORE. THIS IS NOT
THIS IS A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT
THE WORKING WORLD IS LIKE AND IF
STUDENTS SUCH AS MYSELF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. SO THAT
THEY CAN ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS.
EVEN DEMOCRATS STRUGGLING DISARM
THE PROMISE FOR AND P. AND ON
THE DONALD TOUGH. CUSTOMER
STRUGGLE OFFICE ARE NOT. BOTH
MUSICIANSHIP TO. IT'S ALSO OF
CHARGE. ON THE YOU'RE ALSO CLOSE
EXAM WELL A HUNDRED HOURS OF THE
DECISION ARE FREE WELCOME LONG
RUN. ALSO THE COMMUTER I WOULD
DIFFERENT INTERNSHIPS CONTRA.
YOU CAN JUST IN THE TRUMP FOR
CLASS WHEN I COOPER IN A FORTUNE
TO COME ONE IS.
SCHOLARS PROGRAM GREEN UPPER
MARKET ACTUALLY. IN THE LOBBY
COMPANY TO RESERVE BANK. CHANGE
IN MARCH ONE OF THE DIFFERENT. I
WANTED TO DO PART OF THE SITE
I'M FOR THE BETTER TO ONE PERSON
ON THE TIME. I DON'T KNOW DIDN'T
SERVICE THEY NEED TO CONSUME.
WHAT ABOUT THE CAN BETTER FROM.
IF YOU'RE GONNA COME WITH THE
MONEY. ON TO GIVE ALL FOR.
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU MUCH WE
WILL NOW GO TO RE FORTY TWO OR
THREE FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
SPEAK SUPPORT. C. NONE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU CAN UP IN WHO
WAS TO AND SO OF B. EIGHT NINETY
THREE PER. SPEAKING SUPPORT OF
EIGHT THREE PRESS ZERO. WE'RE
NOT TO APPLY NUMBER NINE YEAR
LINES OPEN GO AHEAD- JERRY NAY
SOLO ON THE OF THREE ORGANISER.
THIS MATTEO CAL CHAMBER COMMERCE
THAT SEVEN CAR CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE SAN MATTEO CAL
ACT NOW TO OFFICIALS. COLLEGE OF
AND SO MUCH FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
. NINE TWO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR THE IS JOHN
PENN I'M A TRY OF THE CEMETERY
COUNTY CAN COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
OUR POOR SPONSOR THE SAN TO
BURST BILL TO. EQUITY BY ENABLE
UPWARD SOCIAL IN THAT MODE
THROUGH ITS ATTAINMENT. WELL
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUTE COLLEGE ARE
A GREAT BARGAIN THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW OUR DISTRICT PICK FURTHER
REDUCE BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION
IN OUR ACADEMIC AND CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS WERE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ADELINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD- HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE- THIS ADVENTURE CONSUL
ON ON BEHALF OF- COMPARE. FOR
STATE AND EMPLOYEES VOICE OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL- NUMBER. EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEW MADAM
CHAIR AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL PARTICIPANTS IN Q.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY AGAINST
EIGHT NINETY THREE SEEING NONE
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO. SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO IT NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME- I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
CALLERS QUEUEING UP FOR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SERVE RECORD APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FOR THE L. AND
CERTAINLY MAKE NOTE OF THE
CHALLENGES- YOU'RE- ON. THIS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
YOUR DISTRICT- THE CHALLENGES
THEY FACE. I GUESS THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS AND I APPRECIATE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WHOSE I
THINK WE NEED TO LEARN FROM-
WHAT- FROM IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL IS SIGNED INTO LAW.
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THE IMPACT IS
A QUESTIONS ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE NOW GONNA HAVE
DIFFERENT- THE SCHEDULES AND
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AND WHAT IMPACT OUT
HAPPENED ALSO IMAGINE THAT- THAT
WELL CERTAINLY. MAYBE- THIS
COMMUTE. TOOK ME NOT BE THE ONLY
ONE THAT FACING US SO. ORDER
NUMBER A HIGH COST AREA SO
FORTH- SO GIVE ME CAN YOU JUST
MAYBE BRIEFLY TOUCH ON- YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT. WELL YOU JUST
DECLINING THIS IS A DISTRICT IN
YOUR DISTRICT SO I GUESS THAT
MAKES SENSE- ABOUT- ITS IT'S-
THIS POLICY IN TERMS OF OTHER.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS THAT
MAY BENEFIT FROM THIS. YEAH I
APPRECIATE IT AT LAST WE DIDN'T
START OUT WITH A MORE EXPENSIVE
BILL. AND FEEDBACK I THINK THAT
WE GOT PRETTY CLEARLY WAS TO
FOCUS. ON AND AGAIN IT WAS
REALLY DRIVEN BY THE BOARDS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE ALREADY.
HERE TODAY SO I THINK THAT WITH
THE COMMITTEE MENACE WE WILL GET
THE LEARNINGS SO THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IF IT CAN.
YOU KNOW HELP WHETHER IT'S A IF
IT'S WORKING TO BE CAN HELP
OTHER DISTRICTS I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD COMPROMISE OKAY NOT. EVERY
SHE DIED NINE DOING YES AND YOU
DID TRY OF THE PREVIOUSLY I
THINK PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT DOES THIS REALLY MEAN FOR
THE WHOLE SYSTEM SO BY DOING
THIS IS INDIVIDUAL PILOT THAT
MAKES SENSE. THAT AND BE HAPPY
WITH THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANYONE
ELSE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SEEING NONE CENTER
BURGER WHICH I TO CLOSE. RESPECT
RESTAURANT VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN. MAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE S. B. EIGHT NINE
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE OTOBO AYE MITCHELL
BURKE AYE. COURTESY DALY. DELLY
I'D- GLAZER AYE. PAN FIGHT. AM
HI. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
GET OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT FOR
APPS MEMBERS. THEY YOU SENATOR
BAKER WE HAVE MORE. TODAY S. J.
R. NINE WHICH IS GOING TO BUY
SO. LIMO WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
VERY PRESENT. BY SENATOR PAN.
CENTER PAMPER. WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS
SENATORS ON BEHALF OF CENTER
LIMÓN I'M PROUD TO PRESENT.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION NINE TO
RECOGNIZE OCTOBER TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ENACTMENT OF
AB FIVE FORTY. EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
HAS MAKE COLLEGE ACCESSIBLE FOR
COUNTLESS UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
BY MAKING THEM ELIGIBLE OR IN
STATE TUITION. UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS HAVE HISTORICALLY FACED
BARRIERS THAT RESTRICTED ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION. THE LIMITED
THEIR ABILITY TO WORK AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AB FIVE FORTIES
PROVIDED A PATHWAY FOR DOCUMENTS
USED TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE THEIR EDUCATIONAL AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHEST POTENTIAL.
THAT'S YOUR NINE CALLS ON
CONGRESS TO PASS THE AMERICAN
FAMILIES PLAN. AND PROVIDE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS THROUGH
THE BUDGET RECONCILIATION
PROCESS AND TO ADOPT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. THAT WOULD JUST MAKE
NOTE PERSONALLY THAT- YOU KNOW
WE CAN USE ALL I'M CAPITAL WE
HAVE AVAILABLE- AND THAT
INCLUDES- ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
STUDENTS WE SHOULD BE PROVIDE
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE HELPING
THEM- SURE TO GET A FULL
EDUCATION. BUT THAT EXPECT THE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND I HAVE
WITH ME- TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
IN THE VAST QUIZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN.
MYTHOS GUESS PLEASE. PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. BUT MORE. EVERYONE
LEYVAMEMBER OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME
LINDA. AND I'M BE AT THE BY CHAU
OF THE POLICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS AN
IMMIGRANT AND A FORMER
UNDOCUMENTED CHILD I AM
PERSONALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE AT
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF IT J.
R. NINE SH AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE. GRATITUDE FOR CENTER
LIMB ON FOR LEADERSHIP AND
PERCENT HER PANTS THE PROTECTING
IT TODAY. THIS JOINT RESOLUTION
CELEBRATE THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE FORTY A LANDMARK
LEGISLATION THAT OPEN THE DOORS
TO CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
TO THOUSANDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
PROVIDE THE PATHWAY TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR CITIZENSHIP STATUS TO
PAY IN STATE TUITION FEES AT OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. NOT ONLY DID AB
FIVE FORTY ELIMINATES A BARRIER
TO COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. BECOME
TELL THEIR STATE TO LOOK AT TAKE
A CLOSER LOOK AT OUR POLICIES
AND PRACTICES THAT MAY BE
LIMITING CONTACT WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS SCHNEIDER COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SHOWS. THAT THE PASSAGE
OF EIGHTY FIVE FORTY CALIFORNIA
LEADERS HAVE USHERED IN MAJOR
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
CONTINUED SUPPORTING
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND THEIR
PURSUIT OF A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
AND HE'S INVESTMENT A CALIFORNIA
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED LEADER.
LAST OCTOBER AB FIVE FORTY
CELEBRATED TWENTY YEARS OF
CHANGING LIVES. THIS RESOLUTION
ABOUT CELEBRATE THE
TRANSFORMATIVE WORK OF EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY ALSO CALLED ON
FEDERAL LEADERS TO TAKE ACTION
TO PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
UNDOCUMENTED AND CONTINUE TO
FACE BARRIERS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND IMMIGRANTS MAKE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE AND NATION'S ECONOMY.
MOVING FORWARD. J. R. NINE CALLS
ON CONGRESS TO PASS IMMIGRATION
PROPOSAL INCLUDED AN AMERICAN
FAMILIES PLAN FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS CAN THRIVE AND SUCCEED.
BY REFORMING OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID OUR
COUNTRY CAN ENSURE A STABLE AND. WELCOMING FUTURE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHICH ALL
OTHER TO ACHIEVE THEIR- GOALS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I-
URGE THE FOR THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR TESTING
. ARE WE GONNA MOVE ON TO ANYONE
AND SOME HERE FORTY OH. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE- TESTIFYING IN
SWISS MISTER MODERATED ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE- WITNESSES HERE ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE PLEASE
PROCEED GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY
NAME JOHNSON PRASAD THE VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
AND WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TARA KAZEEM BY SURE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS IN TRANSIT AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR THE SINICIZATION THE
SINICIZATION RECOGNIZES OVER
TWENTY YEARS OF INACTION OF
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY. AND IS IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
SCR NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES WHOSE IN SUPPORT OF
STR NINE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. J.
R. NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE CHILD BY ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
NINE NINE ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE
ONE PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP.
INITIAL SUPPORT FOR- S. J. R.
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO- PUTS
MOMENTARILY THANK YOU NO PROBLEM
-
AND WE WERE LIKE TWENTY HUGH ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CAMILA RODRIGUEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
JEANNIE COMMISSION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. J. R. NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M SURE NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WHO
OPPOSES SJR NINE SEAMEN MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE S.
T. R. NINE PLEASE. I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR S. J.
R. NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. ALABAMA
JUDGE CLOSE THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF CENTER LEMOND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SOMEBODY WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL. CENTER GLAZER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM CONSULTANT
pPLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX S. J. R. NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. LEYVA BY
LEYVA IODORAL BOTH BY. WHICH
WILL BUILD A COURTESY. KELLY
GLAZER. PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
PAN BY AN ICE. VERY GOOD THAT
BILL HAS. NOT ENOUGH IT DOES
OKAY HASN'T HAVE FOLKS TO GET
OUT. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN VOTE. WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH- NUMBER SB EIGHT
FIVE ONE BY CENTER PORTANTINO
MAN CONSULTANT PLEASE. WHICH IS-
OKAY GOT IT ALRIGHT VERY GOOD.
OKAY YEP S. NUMBER TWO S. B.
885% EARLIER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING ON AYE
GLAZER. GLAZER BY MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE CAN MOVE ON TO
SB EIGHT NINETY THREE SENATOR
BAKER PLEASE CALL THE APPS ARE
THERE ANY OF THE MEMBERS NOPE.
OTHER THAN REQUIRE. S. B. NINE
ZERO EIGHT- ALL RIGHT SB NINE
THIRTEEN. AND THEN OUR LAST ONE
S. J. R. NINE AND WE'RE JUST
WAITING ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
WAIT FOR A COUPLE MEMBERS TO
COME IN AND OUT ON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE WILL START WITH OUR OTHER-
HEARING. RIGHT AFTER THAT. THANK
YOU TO OUR STUDENTS ARE WAITING
FOR LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU.
TO OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO COME UP AND SIT IN THE FRONT
ROW AND THEN WHOEVER IS SPEAKING
CAN STEP UP TO THE PODIUM AT
THAT TIME I KNOW THIS IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WE'VE DONE
IN THE PAST BUT- I WANT YOU TO
COME RIGHT UP FRONT AND CENTER
PLEASE.
RIGHT MEADOW CONSULTANT LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ROLE. STARTING WITH
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT FIFTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
FORTY NINE. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS ITSELF SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BYE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE. BY SECURE VOTING AYE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILLS OFF WHAT SEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING ONLINE. COURTESY. MCGUIRE
I SET BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO IS
WELL SEASON VENTURE SIX ZERO
SKEWS ME SIX ZERO ALL RIGHT FILE
. COURTESY HAS NOT YES HE IS A
COMEBACK OF FILE ITEM FOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. NINE ZERO
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ON THE SENATE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
PULLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX S. J. R. NINE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO ROUTING HIGH
PRESSURE VOTING ONLINE. COURTESY
DALY. MCGUIRE WHERE ARE THAT'S
FIVE. THE BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO.
pCALL THE APPS. OF FIVE FIVE I'M
JUST SKIPPING AROUND HERE OUR
TITLES TO THE THAT FILE ITEM
FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
NINE ONE THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE TERROR
VOTING ONLINE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE I'M AT SEVEN. SEVEN
ZERO. ALL RIGHT LET'S TO OUR
LAST BILL SJR NINE. SENATOR
LIMÓN SPELL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX S. J. R. NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING ONLINE COURTESY. COURTESY
I DALY AT SIX ZERO VERY GOOD
THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO I THINK
WE JUST HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL BILL
THREE ADDITIONAL BILLS FOR
CENTER INCREDIBLE AND NUMBER
THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PROTESTING. HI FOR CHEVY II. THE
CENTER VERY GOOD THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR INDIVIDUALS
WHO. ARE PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATIONS WE HAVE CONCLUDED
OUR AGENDA AGENDA THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER AGAIN IN
SIXTY SECONDS.
THANK. ALL RIGHT THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL NONE OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IN THE
CHAMBER WITH ME ARE SENATORS
CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER MCGUIRE A
CHOI BOGUE. CAMPAIGN WE'LL HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE STUDENT
ADVISORY BOARD ON LEGISLATION
AND EDUCATION TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-291-4185 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE GENDER PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT. ON
THE TOPIC ON TODAY'S AGENDA
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST NEED
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
PORT IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED
ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN THE
HEARING. THANK YOU TO OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE HERE THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOR THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD
ON LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION FOR
SABLE. TO PRESENT LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL PROPOSALS DEVELOPED BY
THE STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
STABLE. THESE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS WERE RESEARCHED AND
CRAFTED BY THE STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN STABLE WHICH IS A
DIVISION OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS.
AS WE KNOW FROM THIS ANNUAL
HEARING THE STUDENTS OF STABLE
WORK VERY HARD AT CREATING VERY
THOUGHTFUL PROPOSALS. THE SUIT
STATE BROUGHT IDEAS THAT DEEPLY
IMPACT THEIR DAILY LIVES AND
WORK OVER SEVERAL MONTHS TO FINE
TUNE THEIR IDEAS. INTO GREAT
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. I'VE BEEN
PROUD AUTHORS SEVERAL OF SABLE
PROPOSALS OVER THE YEARS. THIS
MORNING WE HEARD EIGHT STUDENT
TESTIFIED A BILL THAT IS
SPONSORED BY SABLES PARENT GROUP
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO PARTICIPATE TO
COLIN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS
ACCESS CODE. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO. NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST STUDENT MEENA LEE
THE STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENTS. AND LET ME JUST SAY
STUDENTS THIS IS ALWAYS ONE OF
MY FAVORITE HEARINGS I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE HEARING FROM YOU- MS
LI WELCOME BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. I AM VERY PROUD OF PUBLIC
CALIFORNIANS FIFTY. AND I'M A
SENIOR AT JOHN MARSHALL HIGH
SCHOOL FROM LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SENATE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR AN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY FOUR CHAIRWOMAN
LISA AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE I AM HONORED AND ELATED
TO INTRODUCE CASPER PORTAL TODAY
WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR
INCREDIBLE DELEGATES AND
DIRECTOR STEPHANIE WHO. I'M SURE
CALGARY HOLD THAT DEAR PLACE IN
ALL OF OUR HEARTS BUT OTHER
REFRESHER CALCUTTA PERHAPS HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT
PROPOSALS TO THE COMMITTEE.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND
HAS BEEN INTO INSTILLING
LEADERSHIP AND ADVOCACY VALUES
IN STUDENTS SINCE ITS
ESTABLISHMENT IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN. BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. ARE THE PRIMARY
BENEFICIARIES OF THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND AS USED IN GENERATION
HIS MOTIVATION FORTY IMPROVEMENT
AND ADVANCEMENT OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION THINGS NEVER MIND. THE
STUDENTS OF CASKET LIKE TO
EXTEND OUR WARMEST GRATITUDE TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONTINUE TO
CHAMPION STEVEN VOICE TO THE
STUDENT ABOUT SIX STUDENT
ADVISORY. BOARD ON LEGISLATION
IN EDUCATION. WE WOULD LIKE TO
BE WITH. LIKE TO EXTEND OUR
THANKS FOR KEEPING STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE ON WELLNESS AT THE
FOREFRONT ON THE DIFFICULT THIS
DECISIONS. ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACTON OUR
COMMUNITIES. OPTIONS SUCH AS
PASSING SB BY FORTY THE EQUITY
BILL SHOWS STUDENTS AND CAST ALL
GIPSON BUT THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
CONTINUES TO PRIORITIZE OUR
YOUTH BEFORE EVERYTHING ELSE.
THIS CONFERENCE WOULD NOT BE
HAPPY AT THIS CONGRESS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
HELP OF INDIVIDUALS BOTH WITHIN
AND OUTSIDE OF CASK. I WOULD
LIKE TO COMMEND ASSEMBLY CHIEF
CONSULTANT TANYA IT LATER BERMAN
AND SENATE CHIEF CONSULTANT WENT
OVER. FOR NOT ONLY MAKING THIS
JOINT HEARING POSSIBLE BUT ALSO
PROVIDING OUR STUDENTS WITH
VALUABLE ADDITIONAL INSIGHT AND
ARE GERMANTOWN. I WILL ALSO
EXTEND ANOTHER THINGS TO OUR
EXTRAORDINARY CASTS THE COUNCIL
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK PEOPLE.
PUT IN BEHIND THE SCENES. OUR
CONSISTENT PERFORMER
PRESENTATIONS TO THE HONORABLE
COMMITTEE IS NOT ONLY AN
UNPARALLELED OPPORTUNITY FOR
DELEGATES BUT IT UP MOST
RECOGNITION ON BEHALF OF THESE
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION ON THE
INCLUSION OF STUDENT VOICE. WE
THANK YOU ALL FROM THE SIX POINT
THREE MILLION STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
I WELCOME THE CASK EDUCATION
POLICY DIRECTOR SEVENTY WHO FOR
MORE ON TODAY'S PRESENTATIONS
THANK YOU MS LEE AND WELCOME
STEPHANIE WHO AND BEFORE YOU
START IT ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME
THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
MISTER. O'DONNELL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PLEASE PROCEED MRS MISS WHO.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU TO
CHAIRMAN LEYVA AND DETERMINED
I'M A DONALD AND ESTEEMED
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE WHO AND I'M A SENIOR
AT TO SERRA HIGH SCHOOL. AND
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SEVENTY THREE. I SERVE AS THE
EDUCATION POLICY DIRECTOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STUDENT ADVISORY
BOARD ON LEGISLATION AND
EDUCATION CONFERENCE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ALSO THE MAJORITY OF
EVERYDAY TASKS AND EVENTS THE
COPING NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
FORCED US TO ADOPT. THIS YEAR'S
CONFERENCE TO TAKE PLACE
VIRTUALLY WITH EACH STUDENT
CONNECTING FROM THEIR OWN HOMES.
IT HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE HONOR
WITNESSING THE GROWTH OF OUR
FIFTY DELEGATES OVER THE COURSE
OF THREE DAYS. THEIR PASSION FOR
THEIR OWN EDUCATION THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO BE FLEXIBLE AND
THEIR DESIRE TO ACTIVELY WORK
FOR CHANGE ARE SO EVIDENT. EVEN
FROM A COMPUTER SCREEN. AS MANY
STUDENTS NAVIGATE THE AFFECTS OF
DISTANCE LEARNING LAST YEAR WE
ARE INCREASINGLY RIDLEY REAR
INCREASED CREASING REMINDED OF
THE CRITICAL PERSPECTIVES OF THE
STUDENT VOICE. WITH KOBE
NINETEEN AND THIS TRANSITION
AMPLIFYING THE FAULT IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. STUDENT
FEEDBACK WITHIN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM HAS NEVER BEEN BEFORE OF
GREATER CONSEQUENCE. THE
SPEAKERS BEHIND OUR STRONG
WILLED BRILLIANT AND PERCEPTIVE.
THEIR DEDICATION INSPIRES NOT
ONLY ME BUT THE STAFF BEHIND US.
ARE FIFTY DELEGATES DEBATED
VOTED AND DECIDED ON FIVE TOPICS
THAT TRULY EMBODY WHAT THE
DELEGATION USED TO BE AREAS OF
CONCERN THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THESE INCLUDE SERUM
VOICE MENTAL HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTALISM POST HIGH
SCHOOL PREPAREDNESS AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST SCHOOL SAFETY. OVER
THE COURSE OF THREE DAYS THEY
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
COMPRESS ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES IDEAS PASSIONS WANTS
AND NEEDS INTO FIVE THOROUGH
PROPOSALS. DELEGATES BOTH
UNDERSTAND AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL POLICY IDEAS AND HAVE KEPT
THIS IN MIND WHEN BACK IN
BRITAIN EVALUATING ALL POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS. I AM CONFIDENT THAT
ARE THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD
I'M LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION
PRESENTS OUR SOLUTIONS WITHIN
AND CONCERNING OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
WILL BE HEARING TE MOST
PRESSING CONCERNS FOR THE BEST
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR FIRST
PRESENTATION WILL BE ON THE
TOPIC OF STUDENT VOICE PRESENTED
BY AMERICAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS TO MS MERRY KIM
WELCOME PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MERRY KIM
AND I'M A CURRENT SOPHOMORE AT
VERY HIGH SCHOOL IN FULLERTON
CALIFORNIA AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTY FIVE AND SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY NINE. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION TO
DISCUSS THE LACK OF STUDENT
VOICE IN EDUCATIONAL MATTERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT
OF INACCESSIBLE RESOURCES
REGARDING KNOWLEDGE ABOUT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. WITHOUT THIS
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION MANY
STUDENTS ARE LEFT UNINFORMED AND
DISENGAGED FROM THE EDUCATIONAL
GOVERNING BODIES RESULTING IN
THE ABSENCE OF STUDENT VOICE AND
RELEVANT DECISIONS. PLUS WE
PROPOSE THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DISTRIBUTE BI MONTHLY
NEWSLETTERS. TO ALL EDUCATION
PARTNERS SPECIFICALLY TARGETING
STUDENTS CONTAINING THIS
INFORMATION IN PLAIN LANGUAGE.
THESE NEWSLETTERS WILL RAISE
STUDENTS AWARENESS OF THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM INFORM THEM OF
EXISTING OPPORTUNITIES AND
PRESENT AVENUES FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE AND MAKE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENT VOICE IS RIGHTFULLY
REPRESENTED IN EDUCATION
RESOURCES SUCH AS STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS PUBLIC DOCUMENTATION OF
THE EL CAP AND PUBLIC BOARD
MEETINGS AND DISTRICT LEADERS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR YOU TO
EXPLORE. BUT STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
ARE UNEQUIPPED TO UNDERSTAND
THIS INFORMATION. CONSEQUENTLY
THEY CANNOT EXPRESS THEIR
STUDENT VOICES. FURTHER DIRECT
COMMUNICATION THAT DOES EXIST IS
BETWEEN DISTRICT PARENTS WITH
THE FLOOD ASSUMPTION THAT
PARENTS WILL INFORM THEIR
STUDENTS. I FOR ONE IN FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS HAVE NO WAY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH MY BOARD
MEMBER. I KNOW SHE SAYS YEAH
I'VE NEVER HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK
WITH HER TO SHARE MY OPINIONS OR
TO DISCUSS WHAT EVENTS ARE GOING
ON IN OUR DISTRICT. I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT EVENTS WERE BEING
DISCUSSED OR HOW THEY'RE BEING
DECIDED. I SIMPLY DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE TO LOOK. SINCE LIKE ME
COULD NOT MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS COMPETENTLY PERCENT
OUR IDEAS BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
THIS CRUCIAL KNOWLEDGE. BY
CHANCE I FOUND ABOUT SABLE
CASKET AND THE WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY PROVIDE.
AND SINCE THEN I REALIZE HOW I
CAN USE MY VOICE AS A STUDENTS
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AFTER
GETTING MORE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT MY
DISTRICT AND EDUCATION SYSTEM I
STARTED TO SEE MY SCHOOL FROM A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE. HOWEVER I
KNOW THAT MOST OF MY PEERS
CANNOT SEE THE SAME. RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BY THE QUADRI
INSTITUTE FOR SCHOOL VOICE AND
ASPIRATIONS INDICATE THAT
STUDENTS WHO DO BELIEVE THEY
HAVE A VOICE ARE SEVEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE ACADEMICALLY
MOTIVATED. STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A VOICE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO GIVE STUDENTS
THE SPACE TO USE THEIR VOICES BY
QUIPPING THEM WITH THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO COMPREHEND COMPLEX
ISSUES FACING THEIR EDUCATION.
AS SUCH OUR PROPOSAL IS TO HAVE
DISTRICTS DISTRIBUTE BI MONTHLY
NEWSLETTERS CONTAINING THESE
RESOURCES AS WELL AS CURRENT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BOARD OF
THE KING OF EDUCATION MEETINGS
TO STUDENTS AS WELL AS THEIR
FAMILIES AND ALL OTHER RELEVANT
EDUCATION PARTNERS. THESE
NEWSLETTERS WILL CONTAIN THREE
SECTIONS WITH THE INTENTION OF
PREPARING STUDENTS. WITH THE
TOOLS TO UTILIZE THEIR VOICE.
SECTION ONE WILL BE A DEBRIEF OF
THE MOST RECENT BOARD MEETING
WRITTEN IN SIMPLE TERMS BY THE
COMMUNICATION DEPARTMENT FOR
MINUTES WRITTEN BY BOARD CLERK.
SECTION TWO WILL PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AS AN AVENUE FOR
STUDENTS TO SHARE OPINIONS AND
ASK QUESTIONS AND PROVIDING THEM
DIRECT AVENUE TO THEIR BOARD
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS IF
APPLICABLE AND ANY OTHER
RELEVANT GOVERNING BODIES.
SECTION THREE WILL BE A LINKUP
TO EXISTING BOARD WEBSITES WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENT
INVOLVEMENT OPPORTUNITIES SUCH
AS HOW TO SERVE ON DISTRICT
COMMITTEES COMMITTEES A GUIDE TO
UNDERSTANDING THE L. CAP. AND
LINKS TO OTHER FOUNDATIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM. BY CONSISTENTLY
INFORMING STUDENTS WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO ENGAGE IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM WE FULLY
AND EQUITABLY ENABLE STUDENT
VOICES TO BE HEARD. TO GIVE
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE
THEIR VOICES AT AS A CATALYST
FOR CHANGE. WEATHER BEATER
SPEAKING AT DISTRICT COMMITTEE
MEETINGS REACHING OUT TO THEIR
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS OR EVEN
JUST LEARNING THE INS AND OUTS
OF THE ELK. KNOWLEDGE PROCEEDS
EXPRESSION WHICH IS WHY IT IS SO
CRUCIAL THE ACCURATE ACCESSIBLE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED DIRECTLY
TO STUDENTS. WE HELP TO UPLIFT
STUDENTS FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME ACTIVE
INFORMED INFLUENCERS AND MASTERS
OF OUR OWN DESTINY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISS
KIM THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION AND A BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
MISTER CHAIR DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- BUT YEAH
JUST VERY VERY WELL DONE YOUR
PRESENTATION VERY WELL DONE. AND
THIS DOCUMENT HERE IS VERY WELL
KNOWN AS WELL I DON'T KNOW THAT
I'VE SEEN THIS IN PREVIOUS YEARS
MAYBE I HAVE IT DIDN'T TAKE
NOTICE BUT THIS IS A VERY WELL
PUT TOGETHER AND KIND OF A
LEGISLATIVE ASK. FASHION SO-
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT AND-
YEAH I ALSO APPRECIATE I CAN
TELL YOU AND WHAT YOU ALWAYS
HEAR ME TALK ABOUT IS- IN PAST
YEARS AND IS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH BILLS AND IT'S A
VERY EVIDENT TO ME THAT IS THIS-
THAT AS YOUR BILLS IN YOUR
THOUGHTS WERE PUT TOGETHER YOU
CONTEMPLATED. THE FISCAL
ELEMENTS OF YOUR BILLS BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT- SOMETHING WE TALK
ABOUT A LOT BECAUSE A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS HAVE GREAT IDEAS A
HUNDRED TWENTY LEGISLATORS UNDER
RIGHT THEY ALL HAVE GREAT IDEAS
AND THEIR IDEAS THE ONE IDEA
THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO DO NOW
BUT THE THING IS THOSE BILLS
COST MONEY. AND THEY IMPOSE
COSTS ON DISTRICTS WHICH I WOULD
ARGUE ARE ALREADY UNDER FUNDED
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
CAUGHT CONTEMPLATED THE
PRACTICALITY OF YOUR PROPOSALS
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR
PROPOSALS BUT ALSO THAT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER. OKAY I'VE BEEN ON LEAVE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL FOR BODY EIGHT
ALMOST EIGHT YEARS NOW BUT I'LL
BE GOING BACK NEXT FALL- BUT I
DO SOMETHING THE FALL IS BACK IN
THE CLASSROOMS I UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON AT SCHOOL
STRESSES RIGHT NO SIDES ALL THAT
KIND OF THING YOU'VE SEEN IT
YOURSELVES. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY AND HOW
PROFESSIONAL YOU WILL APPEAR IN. YOUR PRESENTATIONS ARE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR OF
THE- AND I AGREE I DON'T READ.
THIS YEARS. EITHER SO MAYBE I
WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION. IT IS
VERY WELL DONE- YOU'LL HAVE A
BRIGHT FUTURE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IF YOU SO CHOOSE TO GO THAT WAY.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND-
REALLY APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT-
THE THOUGHTFULNESS. YES MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS- NIGHT I'M
NOT A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I
ACTUALLY. TIGHTENED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION- SO THURSDAY NIGHT I
HAVE A SON WHO'S IN HIGH SCHOOL-
WE ACTUALLY GET A LOT OF
INFORMATION RIGHT YOUR PHONE
CALLS FROM THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM THE US FROM THE- PRINCIPLE
YOU KNOW. BY THREE EMAILS AND SO
FORTH- HOW DO YOU SEE THE
NEWSLETTER AND- IN TERMS OF
ENGAGING STUDENTS AT SCHOOL SO
YOU TALK **** ABOUT YOUR OWN
EXPERIENCE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT AND SAYING HEY I WANNA GET
MORE INVOLVED IN ON A SURE HOW
BUT I'M SURE AT THE SAME TIME
WHEN YOU'RE IN SCHOOL YOU HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE REALLY
INTERESTED YES- STUDENTS WHO
AREN'T AND- TO CERTAIN EXTENT OF
COURSE ON STUDENTS WHO ARE
WILLING TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION. DO YOU DO YOU HOW
DO YOU SEE SORT OF ENGAGING MORE
STUDENTS- SO YOU CAN PUT
INFORMATION FRONT OF PEOPLE BUT
I THINK THERE'S ALSO THE
ENGAGEMENT PARTY AS WELL THAT
YOU DON'T THIS IS THIS IS
ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
CHANGE AND IS IT TO GET YOUR
VOICE HEARD AND SO FORTH SO- CAN
YOU JUST MAYBE ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- YOU KNOW GIVEN
YOUR EXPERIENCE HOW HOW DO WE
ENGAGE MORE STUDENTS IN THIS
DIALOGUE SO TO ONE ONE PROBLEM
COULD BE IS THAT YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE LEADERS
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT JUST
AREN'T AS AVAILABLE. BUT IF WE
GOT THEM THERE YOU KNOW PARTY
GOOD THANK YOU IS THERE A WAY WE
CAN GET MORE STUDENTS EXCITED
ABOUT THAT I MEAN IT IS THE
FIRST LADY'S ABOUT CIVICS
EDUCATION OVERALL ECONOMY WE CAN
TALK ABOUT COMING TO THE STATE
STAGES OF ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SCHOOL BOARD IS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY RELEVANT I ONLY HOPE
TO STUDENTS AND- WOULD HOPEFULLY
APPRECIATE THAT AT LEAST A
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE A
PRETTY DIRECT IMPACT. ON MONDAY
ABOUT YOUR LIVES. YEAH I THINK
THAT. A BIG. AT LEAST WHAT I SEE
IN IN PIERCE AND- AROUND ME IS
THAT WE A LOT OF. WE HAVE
QUESTIONS. BUT NO ONE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THOSE SO
THEREFORE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO MAKE A CHANGE
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
A CHANGE BECAUSE- THERE'S NO
RESOURCES OR OPPORTUNITIES PUT
IN FRONT OF THEM. TO OOK INTO
THE QUESTIONS TO GET ANSWERS FOR
THE QUESTIONS. SO I THINK WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL AT LEAST AS WE
WERE GOING OVER THIS AT SABLE IS
THAT- WE WANT TO HAVE A MORE
DIRECT AVENUE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SO MANY IDEAS. MAYBE WHO
DON'T TALK ABOUT THEM ALL THE
TIME WHO DON'T PURSUE ANSWERS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO ANSWER
CHOICES FOR THEM. I JUST THINK
THAT THIS NEWSLETTER AND THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO TALK WITH
STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS WHICH IS
BE A STEP FOR STUDENTS. WHO WANT
TO TAKE WHO WANT TO FIND OUT
MORE IT'S AN EASY AVENUE FOR
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO GET ANSWERS
TO THOSE QUESTIONS. THAT'S GREAT
AND I THINK THAT- INFORMATION IS
OF COURSE THE FIRST STEP AND
THEN CREATING SOME SPACES AT
COLUMBIA SPACES IN THE SCHOOL
FOR. SOME VEGETABLES YOU KNOW WE
MAY HAVE AN IDEA BUT- THEY NEED
SOME. COLLECTIVE THINKING RATE
THAT IT HAD A PLACE TO SHARE IT
MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY. DIRECTLY
TO SUPERINTENDENT AND SCHOOL
BOARD RIGHT AWAY BUT HEY LET ME
TO TALK TO MY FRIENDS AND SO
FORTH AND THEN. PEFORM THE
IDEA. AND AND THAT YOU KNOW UP
WITH AS AN EDUCATOR I DO
APPRECIATE AND I AM LOOKING AT
US AS- ASSEMBLY RODADA GOING. UP
WELL ANYTIME WE TRY TO ADD MORE
THINGS IN THE CURRICULUM THE
CRACKLE IS REALLY REALLY FULL
RATE- BUT- THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN. COOPERATE ALSO THE
ENGAGEMENT INTO THE CIVICS
EDUCATION HER RIGHT SO THAT THIS
NEWSLETTER AND THIS AND TALK
ABOUT THESE OPPORTUNITIES. ARE
TIED IN. AND SO IT SERVICE
SERVICE LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT SO WHERE ARE WE WITH DEBT
WHERE PEOPLE CAN LEARN ABOUT
CIVICS AS WELL AS AND THEN. AND
THEN DOES USING A VERY PRACTICAL
WAY SELF. ABOUT THAT NEWSLETTER
MY LOOP AND WITH IT THE WITH
WITH THAT. CURRICULA DEVELOPMENT
CERTAIN PIECEOF CURRICULA. AND
THAT- THAN THAT LINKS THE TWO
TOGETHER SO THAT HOPEFULLY THAT
CAN- PROVIDE PEOPLE EXCITING.
OPPORTUNITIES TO NOT ONLY LEARN
ABOUT SOMETHING BUT THE USE IT
AS THE SAME TIME WELL THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SENT PAN
ANY ELSE CENTER TO A BOOK. I
GOOD. THIRTY SEVEN SERIOUS HERE
I'M ALL VERY MUCH SUPPORT OF A
STUDENT ENGAGED- IN OUR LOCAL
THIS WE ARE HAD- THAT WITHIN
DAYS SCHOOL DISTRICT WELL WE
HAVE A SCHOOL REPRESENTATIVE AT
THE SCHOOL BOARD BUT WE ALSO HAD
D. AB USED BY SRI COMMITTEE
WHICH ACTUALLY HAS A GROUP OF
STUDENTS THAT APPLIED TO HAVE A
VOICE WITHIN THE CITY COUNCIL-
AND HAVE INPUT IN WHAT THE
COMMUNITY THE CITY NEEDS. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OR NEEDS FOR THE
STUDENTS SO I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
OF AN ADVOCATE OF A YOUTH
VOICES- IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
YOU WOULD COME UP WITH THE IDEA
OF A NEWSLETTER CONSIDERING THE
FACT THAT MOST OF OUR YOUTH IS
VERY TECHNOLOGICALLY ENGAGED.
HOW DO YOU THINK TECHNOLOGY AND-
SOCIAL MEDIA COULD ACTUALLY BE
UTILIZED TO MAXIMIZE THE
ENGAGEMENT AT THE INFORMATIVE
PROCESS AND DID YOU TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION MAYBE IN
UTILIZING THAT THOSE PLATFORMS
TO INFORM AND ENGAGE- FELL
STUDENTS. I BELIEVE THAT WHEN
WE'RE DISCUSSING IT WE ARE
SAYING THAT THESE NEWSLETTER LET
LETTERS- COULD BE ALSO EMAILED
OR ONLINE COPIES WHICH I BELIEVE
COULD BE UTILIZED BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF STUDENTS DON'T
CHECK THEIR EMAILS BECAUSE SO
MANY COME IN. THE SUN IS ONE OF
A- YEAH DE. BUT THE ADVERTISE
THESE ON SOCIAL. PLATFORMS LIKE
YOUR SCHOOL A SPECIES INSTANT
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT OR THINGS LIKE
THAT I'M JUST QUICK INFORMATION
WHERE PEOPLE CAN JUST SEE- THIS
IS A LINK THAT I NEED THAT I CAN
USE. TO FIND OUT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENT BOARD
MEETINGS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
INFORMATION- THERE ARE SO MANY
OF RESOURCES TO GET INVOLVED BUT
THE PROBLEM IS JUST THE BRIDGE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE.
STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED ARE
ABLE TO JUST- THE SCOPE SCOLDED
THIS AND CLICK ON IT AND SEE.
WHERE THEY CAN GET INVOLVED SO
YEAH I THINK SOCIAL MEDIA IS.
HUGE WAY THAT. A LOT OF STUDENTS
HAVE IT SAID BE A REALLY GOOD
WAY FOR STUDENTS TO GET
INVOLVED. OVERLY ACCESSIBLE I
THINK USE AND ALSO VERY
INEXPENSIVE WAY OF REACHING OUT
TO THEIR TO THE STUDENTS ARE
RICHEST- WHY DO FOLKS ARE
CONSIDERING I JUST DIDN'T SEE IT
DIDN'T WITH A NEWSPAPER.
SOMETHING PRINTED I THOUGHT. OH
THAT'S MORE FOR OLDER PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF. BUT I WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THE YOU THEY ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT. THEIR THEIR INTEREST IN
OR- YEAH THERE INTEREST IN
ENGAGEMENT SESSION WE AND JUST
MAKING SURE THAT YOU'RE- USING
THAT MAXIMIZING. THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THOSE PLATFORMS AS
WELL THAT GREAT JOB. THANK YOU
SERRA CHAU BOGUE THANK YOU MS
KIM. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR NEXT PRESENTER MODEL
WHO HAS GOT TO MCCULLOUGH PLEASE
CORRECT ME IF I WAS TERRIBLE AT
THAT COME RIGHT UP AND I THINK
YOU'RE A STUDENT LOS ALSO AS
HIGH SCHOOL WHICH IS JUST A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF MY DISTRICT
BUT I THINK IT MIGHT BE YES
SENATOR TO OPPOSE DISTRICT. SO
WELCOME PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING S. C.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MADHU S.
KILEY MCCOLLUM ONE FORTY FIRST
SENATE DISTRICT AND TWENTY THIRD
ST DISTRICT AND I AM A JUNIOR AT
LOS HIGH SCHOOL AND SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY. ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENT
BY THE BOARD ON LEGISLATION
EDUCATION. WE PROPOSE THAT EACH
SCHOOL REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
WELLNESS ADVISOR GROUP. IT'S
PRESENTED A PETITION SIGNED BY
MINIMUM FIVE AND STUDENTS. ARE A
MINIMUM OF 10% A NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ENROLLED HIGH SCHOOL TO
DISTRICT. ATTENDING A SCHOOL
WITH OVER THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND BEGIN CLASSES
RELEASED THIRTY CLASSMATES.
MENTORS KANSI SURROUNDED BY
FRIENDS AND PEERS. I NATURALL
FELT A SENSE OF CLOSENESS AND
COMMUNITY. WITHIN THESE ENSELY
POPULATED PEER GROUPS HOWEVER.
AFTER CO NINETEENTH SENATE THE
CENTER COMMUNITY WAS COMPLETELY
DESTROYED. I FIRST EXPERIENCED
NEGATIVE FACTS A LOCKDOWN SIX
MONTHS MY FRESHMAN YEAR.
OVERWHELMED WITH NO LOG OF WHERE
ARE WHO MARKETS OUT TOO. OFTEN
CAN STAND TO GET OUT OF BED
BECAUSE OF STRESS AND SONYA AND
IF TAKE. I FELT THE DAYS PLAYING
TOGETHER. I FELT DISCONNECTED
AND I FELT LOST I KNOW HOWEVER
THAT MILLIONS OF STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE AND COUNTRY AS A WHOLE
FELT THE SAME WAY. AS STUDENTS
RETURN TO SCHOOL THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS AND ISOLATION IF ENDEMIC
HAS HAD OR MENTAL HEALTH HAS
COME CLEAR. AT MY SCHOOL I KNOW
SAID MANY STUDENTS ROB AND
STRESSED OUT TO THE POINT OF
CRYING. EVEN I WAS OVERWHELMED
BY SADNESS AND STRESS RAMI.
AFTER SHARING MY CONCERNS AND MY
PEERS I WAS REASSURED THAT I WAS
AN ONLY ONE GOING TO STRESS
SLATED ISSUES. I UNDERSTOOD
IMPACTS OF THE CODE NINETEEN
DOMINIC ON MENTAL HEALTH OF
STUDENTS I ALSO REALIZED
INFLUENCE OF PEER TO PEER
COMMUNICATION. BECAUSE OF THE
STATUS QUO. MANY SCHOOLS ARE NOT
PROPERLY FALL MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES AND EFFECTIVE SECOND
SPORTS STUDENTS. AND THIS LACK
OF ACCESSIBILITY WE STUDENTS
FEELING AS IF THEY HAVE NO SAFE
OUTLET TO SHARE AND EXPECT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND CONCERNS
. I START WISHING STUDENT VIæT
GROUPS. UBISOFT FOSTERING A SAFE
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
STUDENTS CAN COLLABORATE ON
ISSUES RELATING MENTAL HEALTH TO
RAISE AWARENESS. THESE ADVISORY
GROUPS WOULD GIVE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK ON A LOOK
OUT FOR EACH OTHER WILL ALSO
BRING ABOUT MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
. ESPECIALLY DURING THIS PERIOD.
ON YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH HAVE BEEN
IT'S CLEAR IS A CRISIS AND ONE
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION. 81%
TEEN YEARS EXPERIENCE MORE
STRESSED ARTICLE NINETEEN DOWN
AT. SCHOOL SHOULD NOT ONLY FOCUS
ON THE FISCAL IMPACT A CO
NINETEEN BUT ALSO ON THE MENTAL
IMPACT. WHICH IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT. IF SOMEONE IS IMPACT
BY PHYSICAL ILLNESS AND A LOT OF
INCE'S SOMETHING CAN EASILY
NOTICE AND HELP CAN EASILY
ATTAINED. HOWEVER IF SOMEONE IS
UNDERGOING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
RECOGNIZE THE SYMPTOMS BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE. SCHOOLDIGGER
SONYA CO NINETEEN- TO HANSON
TANK STATIONS AND TO
DISTRIBUTION OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. BUT WE
STUDENTS FEEL LACK OF SUPPORT
FOR OUR SCHOOLS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH. SCHOOLS SHOULD FOSTER
ENVIRONMENT THAT ACTIVELY WORKS
TO ENSURING THAT BOTH STUDENTS
AND STAFF WHO COMFORTABLE ABOUT
DISCUSSING MENTAL HEALTH. BISHOP
ADEQUATE ACCESSIBLE RESOURCES
AND MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. UNDER
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE I BEING
ACTIVELY ADDRESSED AND
PRIORITIZED. TO RESPOND TO THIS
ISSUE WE PROPOSE SIX EACH GOAL
FOR ME QUIETEST ALLOWANCE VIæT
GROUP TO ADDRESS STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS. THESE WALLETS
VISOR GROUPS WILL BE ESTABLISHED
AUTOMATIC FROM OSTENTATION
REACHES MINIMUM SIGNATURES BY
FIVE AND STUDENTS ARE MINIMUM OF
10% OF NUMBER SIGNATURES FROM
STUDENTS REGULAR AND BOLD AND
SCHOOL DISTRICT. TRUEST PROCESS
STUDENTS WILL DRAW ATTENTION TO
THE TOPIC OF MENTAL HEALTH.
SINCE YOU WILL TO SHARE OPINIONS
ON MENTAL HELD WITHIN THESE
ADVISORY GROUPS WILL ALSO
REPORTING DEFINING TO
FACILITATOR WHO RESPONSIBLE
COMMUNICATING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THE DETAILS AND
FACILITATION COMMITTEE IS FREE
FOR EACH WILL DECIDE ON BASED ON
WHAT THEY SEE FIT. WHILE ALSO
BEING PROVIDED WITH SUPPORT FROM
TRAINS SOCIAL WORKERS ARE MENTAL
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDED BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE HOPE HAT
WOULD OUR PROPOSAL SCHOOLS ABLE
TO FOSTER AND FAX INCLUSIVE
VARMINT WHERE STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO CHECK IN WITH EACH OTHER AND
SHARE MEDICAL CONCERNS. HE'S
WON'T ADVISORY GROUPS WOULD
ALLOW STUDENTS TO SHARE OPINIONS
ON MEDICAL TOPICS THAT MATTER TO
THEM. THIS INITIATIVE WOULD BE A
STEP FORWARD TO DECREASE THE
STATE NOT NOT HOLD IN SOCIETY
STARTING AT SCHOOLS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS JUST AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TOPIC- AND HEARING FROM YOU KNOW
WE HAVE IDEAS OF SOME OF US HAVE
SCHOOL I DON'T HAVE SCHOOL AGED
CHILDREN BUT TO HEAR FROM YOU
AND I DO WORRY ABOUT OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS- BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST SO
LARGE AND LIKE YOU SAID FEELING
SOMEWHAT LOST. SO I REALLY DO
LOVE THIS IDEA BEFORE I ASK MY
QUESTIONS I'M AN OPEN IT UP TO-
MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO ASK. SIR-
CHAU FOLK. I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS THEM IN A HUGE ADVOCATE
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH- ADVOCACY
AND- REALLY TRYING TO GARNER
BOTH THE RESOURCES AND THE
SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR OUR OUR
STUDENTS AND JUST IN CALIFORNIA
IN GENERAL I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE UNDERLYING COMMON THEMES
THAT I'VE HEARD ACROSS THE
STATE- AND ALSO OBVIOUSLY WITHIN
ARE YOU THAT YOU HAVE A SIXTEEN
YEAR OLD IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND OUR
SOLICITOR HAS TRULY TRY TO BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONCERNS IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
SO I. AM IN COMPLETE SUPPORT OF
TRYING TO- SUPPORT ADAM WHAT IT
ESPECIALLY WITH THEIR LARGER
HIGH SCHOOLS TODAY- IT. WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB ON THAT AND I
THINK IT IT BEHOOVES ALL OF US
TO ONE OF THE REASONS ACTUALLY
THAT I RAN FOR OFFICE- WAS
BECAUSE OF THE TOXIC NATURE THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR SOCIETIES AND WE
NEED TO START CHANGING THAT THE
MODELING AND DIFFERENT WAY OF
SPEAKING AND EARNED IN TONE IN
IT GOVERNING. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND DEBT BE SURE TO
CONNECT WITH OUR OFFICE- IN THE
DISTRICT BECAUSE I WOULD LOVE TO
BE A PARTNER. IN THIS ENDEAVOR.
YOU MAY HAVE JUST FOUND AN
AUTHOR FOR YOUR BILL NO PRESSURE
CENTER CHOI BOGUE. CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE- BEGAN GROUP
COMING TOGETHER AND THE THINKING
THROUGH THIS ISSUE- MAKE NOTE
THAT- BILLS. IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND- WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION DEBTS LAST YEAR
WE PASSED DAYS ACTUALLY FOUR AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS USE
MENTAL HEALTH INITIATIVES- AND-
SO I THINK- I'M HOPING THAT-
WITH YOUR IDEAS AND WHAT YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT WE CAN PUT THESE
PIECES TOGETHER- I WAS THE ONE
THE BIG CHALLENGES WE HAVE IS. A
LACK OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS- I MEAN THERE'S A LOT
OF. HEALTH ISSUES GOING ON AND-
AND THEN IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME TO
TRAIN MORE MORE- MORE PROVIDERS-
SO BE REAL PROVIDERS SO WE NEED
TO ALSO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
LEVERAGE OTHER REOURCES
INCLUDING PEER SUPPORTS IS
YOU'RE PROPOSING- BE A PRIMARY
CARE. PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS AND OTHERS TO THE END
AND THAT NO PART OF PROPOSAL
FROM ADMINISTRATIONS ALSO TO
HAVE THESE TRAIN COACHES WAS
SUMMONED HEALTH COACHES AS WELL.
AND SO I THINK GOOD GROUP REALLY
LOVE TO SEE IS- TAKING THE IDEAS
THAT YOU PRESENTED HERE AND
SEEING HOW WE INTEGRATED INTO
THIS MENTAL HEALTH INITIATIVES
FOR USE AND OF COURSE WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU ABOUT HOW THESE
THINGS WORK- BECAUSE- IF IT'S
NOT WORKING FOR YOU IT'S NOT
WORKING PERIOD. SO AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT PRESENTATION
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH A
WITH ALL OF YOU AND WON'T BE
SURE BUT WE TALK ABOUT THE VOICE
WILL BE SURE WE HEAR YOUR VOICE
NOW AND SCHOOL BOARDS MIGHT BE
SURE YOUR VOICE IS HEARD AND-
YOU KNOW AT THAT THE PART OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THAT
ARE DEVELOPING THIS INITIATIVE
AS. WELL SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER. SO I HAVE A QUESTION A
DO YOU ENVISION THIS BEING- S.
LIKE A CENTER THE WELL- THE
ADVISOR GROUP TO HIS OF BEING
LIKE A CENTER STUDENTS COULD
DROP IN WHEN THEY NEED TO OR DO
A VISION IT MORE AS A GROUP THAT
MEETS WEEKLY OR DAILY. WHAT IS
YOUR VISION. OUR ACCOUNT IS
PRESENT PROPOSAL TO SABLE WITH
VISION THIS MOSTLY AS PERIODIC
MEETING. IN WHICH STUDENTS CAN
COLLABORATE ON ISSUES REALLY
MENTAL HEALTH. ALL TO SHARING
YOUR NEED TO CONCERNS. FAIL TO
ADDRESS HOW MENTAL ISSUES ARE
AFFECTING YOUR SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR PEERS.
THEY CAN WORK TOGETHER TO FIND
SOLUTIONS AL TO REPORTED SHE WAS
STILL TATER. IS TO SEE HOW THEY
CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANOTHER
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK. YES
I'M SORRY YEAH JUST A PERSONAL
TO YOUR PRESENTATION VERY WELL
DONE VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT. VERY
PROFESSIONAL- TO THE STRUCTURE
OF YOUR BILL- GOOD JOB- I AND I
LIKE THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME
LOCAL BINA SUCH DISTRICT MANDATE
. AGAIN GOING BACK TO WHAT KIND
OF WHAT I BELIEVE I SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHOULD RUN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NOT THE STATE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS ISN'T JUST
HEY YOU HAVE TO DO THIS IS A-
THERE'S A THERE'S A PROCESS FOR
SCHOOLS TO DO THIS. AND MENTAL
HEALTH WE ALL KNOW IS A HUGE
ISSUE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL SO IT'S AN ISSUE RIGHT
NOW FOR STUDENTS. ACTUALLY AN
ISSUE FOR TEACHERS AS WELL. I'LL
TELL YOU THIS PLACE IS CLOSE FOR
MONTHS BUT SCHOOLS WERE OPEN.
AND SCHOOLS WERE OPEN- AT LEAST.
YOU KNOW AS OF THIS FALL- BUT
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THIS AND-
THIS IS- AN ISSUE I'VE SEEN IN
MY OWN HIGH SCHOOL I TEACH AT A
LARGE HIGH SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE A SIX YEAR OLD IN
HIGH SCHOOL AS WELL. AND I KNOW-
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES I SEE
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING I
COULDN'T DIAGNOSIS I COULDN'T
TREAT IT BUT I KNEW. A STUDENT
HAD SOME CHALLENGES AND I HANDED
OFF TO THE COUNSELOR BUT I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT STUDENT OR OR WHAT THE
COUNSELOR DID WITH. WITH WITH MY
RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY CHECK
IN WITH THAT STUDENTS SO WE DID
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WAS AROUND A
BILL. TO ESTABLISH SCHOOL SITE
PROTOCOLS. MEANING EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHALL DEVELOP POLICY.
RIGHT AGAIN NOT A STRICT MANDATE
BUT SHALL AS SHALL DEVELOP A
POLICY THAT FITS THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT- SO WHEN- CANCERS ARE
ALERTED TO A STUDENT WITH MAYBE
A SITUATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
CHECKED IN UPON- IT IS THERE IS
FOLLOW THROUGH RIGHT THERE'S A
THERE'S- KINDA. A PATH- SO THAT
THAT THAT IS AGAIN SOMETHING
I'VE DONE WITH MY OWN EXPERIENCE
BUT YOU BRING IN THIS FOR THE IS
A- IS A GREAT THING AND I AND-
AND VERY INTERESTING IDEA. LOOK
IT UP. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MR. GOTTA SAY IT FOR
ME ONE TIME. BUT I STARTED A
CALL GOT HIM A COLLAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WE APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT
NEXT UP IS MISS IRENE KIM FROM
MISSION VISTA HIGH SCHOOL PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING IS THE MEMBERS OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
IRENE. DISTRICT AND THIRTY SEVEN
SENATE DISTRICT ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION EDUCATION WE PROPOSE
THAT ALL SCHOOLS BE REQUIRED TO
MAKE RECYCLING AND COMPOST BINS
ACCESSIBLE AROUND CAMPUS EACH
ACCOMPANIED BY EDUCATIONAL SIGNS
THAT CLARIFY THE CONTENTS OF THE
BINS IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
FOOD CHER TABLES IN CAFETERIAS
TO REDUCE FOOD WASTE. WHEN I
WALK INTO SCHOOL I SEE GARBAGE
CANS OVERFLOWING WITH PLASTIC
BOTTLES JUICE CARTONS AND PAPER.
ALL RECYCLABLE ITEMS. WITH THE
AMOUNT OF SINGLE USE RECYCLED
MATERIALS THAT WE PRODUCE AS A
SCHOOL WE SHOULD HAVE RECYCLING
BINS SPREAD OUT ACROSS EVERY
CORNER OF OUR CAMPUS. NONE THE
LESS I SEE NO COMPOST BINS AND
FEW RECYCLING BINS WHICH GO
IGNORED BECAUSE STUDENTS DON'T
KNOW WHAT CAN AND CANNOT BE
RECYCLED. WHEN SCHOOLS DO NOT
ACTIVELY PUSH FOR STUDENTS TO
PRACTICE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY THEY ARE BEING
COMPLACENT ABOUT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. THE LACK OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES THAT MY SCHOOL AND
MANY SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEE MAKE ME EXTREMELY
CONCERNED FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR
EARTH. LUCKILY THERE IS A
SOLUTION. BY RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING WE CAN SLOW DOWN
POLLUTION PREVENT OVERFLOWING
LANDFILLS AND LESSEN OUR IMPACTS
ON NATURAL HABITATS. IN ADDITION
EXPOSING STUDENTS TO GOOD
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING
PRACTICES WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO
IMPLEMENT BACK THEM BACK HOME
AND ELSEWHERE. PROVIDING
STUDENTS WITH THE ABILITY TO
RECYCLE AND COMPOST AT SCHOOL IS
IMPERATIVE FOR THE WELLNESS OF
OURSELVES AND OUR WORLD. SCHOOLS
GENERATE OVER HALF A MILLION
TONS OF WASTE EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTING
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE BUILD UP IN
OUR LIMITED LANDFILL SPACE.
NEARLY HALF OF SCHOOL WASTE IS
RECYCLABLE OR COMPOSTABLE
CARDBOARD PLASTIC BOTTLES FOOD
BUT THE LACK OF RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING BINS LEAVE STUDENTS
NO OPTION BUT TO THROW AWAY
THESE MATERIALS AND GENERAL
GARBAGE BINS. EVEN STUDENTS WERE
OFFERED THE ABILITY TO RECYCLE
AND COMPOST AT SCHOOL MAY LACK
THE KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO PROPERLY
DO SO. IN LIGHT OF THESE
OBSERVATIONS AND EXPERIENCES MY
GROUP MEMBERS AND I PROPOSE THAT
ALL PUBLIC CALIFORNIA K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS BE EXPECTED TO
IMPLEMENT RECYCLING AND COMPOST
BINS AROUND THEIR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES ALONG WITH
INFORMATIONAL SITE. SIGNAGE THAT
EXPLAINS WHAT GOES IN EACH BIN.
THE FUNDING FOR EDUCATIONAL
SIGNS AND THE INITIAL PAYMENT
AND REPLACEMENT OF THESE BINS
WOULD BE PROVIDED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION GRANT
PROGRAM OR F. A LEGIBLE
REIMBURSED BY THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD MAKE
AGREEMENTS WITH LOCAL RECYCLING
AND COMPOSTING CENTRES TO
DISPOSE OF RECYCLABLE AND
COMPOSTABLE MATERIALS INCLUDING
AGREEMENTS WITH VENDORS TO
PROVIDE BINS AND MANAGE WASTE.
OUR PROPOSAL WOULD COMPLEMENT
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WHICH AIMS FOR A 75%
REDUCTION IN LANDFILL ORGANIC
WASTE FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BY PROVIDING
AN AVENUE FOR SCHOOLS TO ARRANGE
FOR RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING
SERVICES. WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
MULTIPLE DISTRICTS PUSH FORWARD
SO MUCH SIMILAR PLANS. THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR EXAMPLE IMPLEMENTED A WASTE
REDUCTION AND RECYCLING PROGRAM
THAT TEACHES STUDENTS A STABLE
PRACTICES. THROUGH THESE
PRACTICES THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS SAVED OVER
THREE THOUSAND TREES TWELVE
MILLION GALLONS OF WATER AND
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TRASH DISPOSAL COSTS. IN
ADDITION WE PROPOSE THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS PROVIDE FUTURE TABLES IN
CAFETERIAS FOR STUDENTS TO PLACE
THEIR UNWANTED FOOD ITEMS ON.
OTHER STUDENTS CAN THEN TAKE THE
ITEMS ON THIS TREE OR HAVE THE
ITEMS DONATED REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD WASTE GENERATED.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD MODEL
SAFETY STANDARDS OF OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH
WITH A FUTURE TABLE PROGRAM HAS
DONATED EXTRA FOOD TO THOSE IN
NEED WHILE LIMITING FOOD WASTE
AMONG ITS THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. BY IMPLEMENTING THIS
PRACTICE STUDENTS WILL LEARN HOW
TO RECYCLE AND COMPOST AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUSTAINABLE WASTE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICING ENVIRONMENTALISM FOR
A MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. WE
ASK STUDENTS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TAKING CARE OF THIS EARTH FOR
OUR GENERATION AND FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO COME THEREFORE WE
WILL NOT STAND IDLY BY AT IS AS
IT IS POLLUTED AND SLOWLY
DESTROYED. OUR HOPE IS THAT WHEN
ALL STUDENTS WALK INTO THEIR
SCHOOLS THEY'LL FEEL ENCOURAGED
TO BE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
AND KNOW THAT THEIR SCHOOLS WERE
WILL PROVIDE THE MEANS TO DO SO.
A NECESSITY TO CONSERVE OUR
PLANET'S EXHAUSTED WILL
RESOURCES AND ENSURE A HEALTHIER
FUTURE FOR ALL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU THAT IS
THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION AND I AM A- BIG FAN
OF RECYCLING AND I'M ALSO A BIG
PEOPLE WHO WILL THEN NOT ONLY DO
IT THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE. BUT
ALSO GO HOME AND- TEACH THEIR
FAMILIES ABOUT THAT TO HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
OUR OUR BOARD- I JUST JUST
QUICKLY- AGAIN VERY VERY WELL
PRESENTED- AND I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT. YOU GUYS GO TO HIGH
SCHOOL RIGHT SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF FOOD WASTE IN HIGH
SCHOOL SO IT'S KIND OF A NO
BRAINER. THAT SCHOOLS SHOULD
OFFER- BINS FOR FOOD WASTE
SOLELY FOOD WASTE. TO COMPOST
ETCETERA- SO IT'S REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU BRING TO THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD- AS YOU
WERE SPEAKING I WAS CHECKING
WITH OUR STAFF TO SEE IF WE HAVE
A SPOT BILL AVAILABLE THAT
POSSIBLY WE COULD CARRY THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS TO ME EVERY YEAR YOU
COME A PERCENT THESE AMAZING
IDEAS AND I JUST THINK THAT THIS
WOULD BE VERY- THIS WOULD CHANGE
A LOT AND IT COULD BE DONE AT
ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS SO. CONTACT
US WILL CONTACT YOU WILL SEE IF
WE CAN'T MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD
BUT EXCELLENT PRESENTATION AND
JUST RIGHT ON THE MARK AT THE
RIGHT TIME SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS KIM. YES CENTER MAY I
ADD SOMETHING. I'M GOING TO JUMP
OUT TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE HEARING
THE LEGISLATURE'S KIND OF ODD
AND IT'S KIND OF LIKE. I GUESS
COUNTY HAVING TWO CLASSES AT THE
SAME TIME IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT-
I'LL BE ON A COMMITTEE AND I'LL
BE ON. SEVERAL COMMITTEES AND
SOME OF COMMITTEES WILL MEET AT
THE SAME TIME. SO IF YOU SEE
SENATORS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BOUNCING AROUND. IT MEANS THAT
THEY PROBABLY HAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING GOING ON RIGHT
NOW SO I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
ABSENT A LITTLE BIT BUT- AND
IT'S- GREAT JOB ALL OF YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT SO
DON'T THINK THAT IF SOMEONE
LEAVES IS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED WE DO GET. DOUBLE AND
TRIPLE SCHEDULED. AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE IT ALL WORK. SO
BUT YOU'RE STUCK WITH ME THE
WHOLE TIME. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL FOR
BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
ALL RIGHT- AND AGAIN THANK YOU
MISS KIM AND WE WILL BE IN
TOUCH. OUR NEXT PRESENTER- IS R.
NOV WERNER. AND YOU ARE A
STUDENT AT MONTA VISTA HIGH
SCHOOL PLEASE PRESENT WHEN YOU
ARE READY. TO. GOOD MORNING IS
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ARGHA VERMONT AND I AM A JUNIOR
AND MONTAVISTA HIGH SCHOOL. I AM
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN
AND SENATE DISTRICTS SIX. ON THE
BEHALF OF STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
I AM HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE RISING
IMPORTANCE. OF FINANCIAL
LITERACY EDUCATION BUT FIRST.
LET ME TELL YOU A STORY. LAST
YEAR WHEN MY BROTHER WENT OFF TO
COLLEGE WITHIN A MONTH HE
DRAINED HIS BANK ACCOUNT. WITH
BAFFLING PURCHASES. FROM KNOCK
OFF DESIGNER CLOTHING TWO EIGHT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
FISH TANK. WELL AFTER MAKING A
COUPLE JOKES AT HIS EXPENSE WITH
MY FRIENDS. THE CONVERSATION.
QUICKLY TURNED TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SOUND FINANCIAL
DECISIONS. BECAUSE MY BROTHERS
WERE ANYTHING BUT- THROUGH THIS
I REALIZED THAT SHE WASN'T ALONE
IN HIS STRUGGLES WITH FINANCES.
SO ON THE BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
DELEGATION WE PROPOSE THAT
SCHOOLS INTRODUCE HIGH SCHOOL
UPPERCLASSMEN TO FINANCIAL
LITERACY THREE RECORDED VIDEO
PRESENTATION THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE. OF BEING FINANCIALLY
LITERATE ALONG WITH THE
RESOURCES TO ALLOW THEM TO
FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION ON THE
TOPIC. IN TODAY'S SOCIETY
FINANCIAL LITERACY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY WITH MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE USING CREDIT
CARDS AND UNDERTAKING COMPLEX
FINANCIAL DECISIONS THAN EVER
BEFORE. WHILE PASSION RATIONS
HEAVILY RELIED ON COMPANY PAID
PENSIONS OR BENEFIT PLANS.
EMPLOYERS DO USE FOR ONE K.
PLANS WHEN THEY DECIDE WHERE
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTION AND THEIR
INVESTMENT GOES. KNOWING HOW
CHECKING ACCOUNTS AND CREDIT
CARDS WORK ARE BOTH INTEGRAL TO
ADULTHOOD BECAUSE DESPITE WHAT I
BELIEVE A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
MONEY DOESN'T JUST APPEAR ON THE
CARD WHENEVER MY PARENTS ARE
FEELING GENEROUS. AND WHILE THIS
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE MAY SEEM LIKE
A PERSONAL PROBLEM. IT HAS BROAD
IMPLICATIONS FOR OVERALL
ECONOMIC HELP. FOR EXAMPLE JUST
TAKE A LOOK AT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FINANCIAL CRISIS WARLOCK
OF MORTGAGE PRODUCT
UNDERSTANDING LET BORROWERS TO
BE VULNERABLE TO PREDATORY
LENDING. RESULTING IN A CLUB
FROM WHICH MANY HAVE STILL NOT
RECOVERED. VITAL FINANCIAL
KNOWLEDGE SHOULD BE EMPHASIZED I
DON'T EARLY AGE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS SIMPLY DO NOT PROVIDE
SUCH OPPORTUNITIES. AT HIGH
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL COURSES ARE NOT
OFFERED LEAVING MANY STUDENTS TO
FEEL UNPREPARED FOR WHAT COMES
POST GRADUATION. THIS ISSUE IS
ALSO OBSERVED AT MY HIGH SCHOOL
MONTAVISTA HIGH SCHOOL IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY WHERE MOST STUDENTS
FEEL LOST AND CONFUSED WHEN IT
COMES TIME TO MAKE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS. LEADING THEM TO MAKE
BRASH PURCHASES LIKE SAY IF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLAR FISH
TANK. EVEN MORE SERIOUS MANY OF
MY SENIOR FRIENDS DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS OF
STUDENT LOANS AND HOW OLD AFFECT
THEIR LIVES POST GRADUATION.
SUFFICE TO SAY MANY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE UNPREPARED FOR
LACK AFTER A FOR LIFE AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL MUCH OF WHICH IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE LAC OF
FINANCIAL LITERACY. AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA WAS GIVEN
AN F. BY THE CHAMPLIN COLLEGE
CENTER FOR FINANCIAL LITERACY
FOR ITS ABILITY TO PRODUCE
FINANCIALLY LITERATE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES. AND I SUCH THERE IS A
CLEAR IMPERATIVE TO SHIFT THE
PARADIGM AND IMPROVE THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL THE KNOWLEDGE OF OUR
STUDENT POPULATION. AND WE MUST
START WITH THE U. OUR PROPOSAL
WOULD REQUIRE STUDENTS. OR WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO INTRODUCE
FINANCIAL LITERACY TO ALL
STUDENTS BY SHOWING IS REALLY
PRESENTATION THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FINANCIAL LITERACY
OR IMPLEMENTING A FINANCIAL
LITERACY COURSE INTO THEIR
CURRICULUM. SCHOOLS USING A
VIDEO PRESENTATION WOULD HAVE
TWO OPTIONS ONE VIDEO THAT WOULD
BE CREATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OR TO.
READ THEIR OWN PRESENTATION
SUBJECT TO APPROVAL OF THE
DISTRICT GOVERNING BOARD TO
ALLOW FOR MORE LOCAL CONTROL.
THE VIDEOS WOULD COVER TOPICS
BEEN INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO MONEY MANAGEMENT TAXES CREDIT
AND LIVING EXPENSES. AND BY
DOING SO WE WILL IMPROVE THE
FOUNDATIONAL FINANCIAL KNOWLEDGE
OF THE YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA.
FINANCIAL KNOWLEDGE POSITIVELY
IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITY BY
IMPROVING RATES OF SAVINGS
LOWERING LEVELS OF DEBT AND
INCREASING RATES OF HOUSEHOLD
WEALTH ACCUMULATION. MOREOVER AS
FINANCIAL LITERACY IS LINKED
WITH THE ABILITY TO ESCAPE
POVERTY. WE WILL BE PROVIDING
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS WITH THE
MUCH NEEDED UPWARDS MOBILITY AND
GIVING OUR YOUTH VALUABLE
INFORMATION THAT WILL SERVE THEM
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
THEREFORE WE URGE YOU TO MEET
OUR MINIMUM REQUIRED TO APPROVE
OUR MINIMUM REQUIREMENT WHICH
WILL ACCENTUATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF FINANCIAL LITERACY EXPOSE
STUDENTS TO CRUCIAL FINANCIAL
TOPICS. AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO
PURSUE MORE FINANCIAL KNOWLEDGE.
I URGE YOU TO PRIORITIZE SETTING
CALIFORNIANS TUNES ON THE RIGHT
PATH TO BECOMING MORE
FINANCIALLY LITERATE AND
CREATING A NEW PARADIGM OF
PROSPERITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER PANDA
GERMANY COMMENTS. THANK THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION- ACTUALLY- I KNOW
THAT- LOCALLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ARE UNITED WE ACTUALLY INVESTED
A LOT AND FINANCIAL LITERACY
PARTICULAR FOR FOSTER YOUSEF
WHO- OFTENTIMES. BECAUSE OF
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES STILL HAVE
AS MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO. GAIN
THIS EXPERTISE- THIS KNOWLEDGE I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU. IS
THAT- WE AT SURPRISED RELATED TO
THE FIRST PRESENTATION AROUND
THE ALSO THE STUDENT GAUGE MEANT
IS THAT- WE CAN PUT THE
INFORMATION IN FRONT OF PEOPLE I
MEAN IF YOU'RE HERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL YOU KNOW YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
PAY ATTENTION CLASS AND SO
FORTH- HOW. HOW DO WE DO THIS IN
A WAY THAT'S NOT PERHAPS MORE.
ENGAGING INTERACTIVE SO PEOPLE
CAN. MAKE THE CONNECTIONS ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT WHAT THEY'RE
LEARNING IS SO. I THINK THAT
POLICE MANY EDUCATORS I TALKED
TO HER SCHOOL DISTRICT'S NON NON
SAYS WELL FINANCIAL LITERACY IS
IMPORTANT SO- BUT HOW DO YOU
INTEGRATE INTO THE CURRICULUM
AND THEN ALSO DO IN A WAY
THAT'S- ENGAGING ENOUGH SO THAT-
PEOPLE PAY ATTENTION RIGHT. AND
IS IT IS IT AT THE RIGHT YEAH
AND HOW DO YOU DO IN A WAY THAT
SORT OF- TARGETS- THE CHALLENGES
THAT STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
FACING SO. I'LL TELL YOU THAT-
NIGHT A TV AND I TEACH. HIGHER
EDUCATION- AND THEN YOU WOULD
THINK THAT YOU KNOW I SCHOOL
STUDENTS YOU THINK FOR THE LONG
THAT- YOU MIGHT. THIS MIGHT BE
MORE IMPORTANT AND- IT'S STILL
AMAZING HOW OFTEN PEOPLE- YOU
KNOW YOU START TALKING ABOUT
FINANCIAL LITERACY MISTER TUNING
YOU OUT. WILL I HAVE OTHER
THINGS ARE MORE IMPORTANT TO ME.
SO I THINK YOU MAKE AN EXCELLENT
CASE ABOUT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
PRESENTED- I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA. I AM JUST INTERESTED
AND THINKING ABOUT HAVE YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT HOW DO YOU BETTER
ENGAGE STUDENTS- SO. GREAT WILL
DO A PRESENTATION AND- HOW DO WE
ENGAGE PEOPLE SO THAT THEY- IN A
WAY THAT IT'S- THAT THEY SEE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO THEM AND DO
IN A WAY THAT'S INTERACTIVE AND-
AND REALLY ENGAGES THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THERE. BECAUSE I'M SURE
YOU HAVE PLENTY OF PRESENTATIONS
HE SAID THROUGH AN CLASS WHERE
YOU'RE LIKE OKAY WELL THAT'S
NICE AND- BUT I DON'T SEE HOW
CONNECTS TO ME HOW GREAT SO- AND
THEN MAYBE YOU'RE OUT REALLY
GOOD STUDENTS IS A WELL ANYWAY
I'M GONNA REALLY PAY ATTENTION
BUT- YOU ALSO HAVE CLASSMATES
WHO ARE LIKE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME- IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE IT'S CONNECTED TO MY LIFE.
I HAVE OTHER THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT THEY'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION. BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION AND I'M REALLY.
TO HEAR THAT YOU DISTRICT HAS
INVESTED IN FINANCIAL LITERACY.
SO I THINK. THERE IS THIS
GENERAL CONSENSUS THAT THERE IS
APATHY IN SCHOOL WELL ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU. TOOK A TAKE A LOOK AT
SUBJECTS LIKE MATH PEOPLE SAY
ONE OF MY GOING TO USE THIS IN
THE REAL LIFE. BUT I THINK
FINANCIAL LITERACY IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT BECAUSE- IT INHERENTLY
APPLIES TO ALL OF US- AND THE
SECOND PROBLEM. I THINK. IS LACK
OF ACCESSIBILITY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE- ALTHOUGH A LOT OF
SCHOOLS OFFER ECONOMICS CLASSES
DOES NOT THE SAME AS FINANCIAL
LITERACY. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON THAT. BUT MANY STUDENTS
AT MY SCHOOL FOR EXAMPLE DON'T
HAVE. ACCESS TO THOSE RESOURCES
RIGHT THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
SEARCH THEY DON'T HAVE. PEOPLE
TELLING THEM HERE'S WHERE YOU
CAN LOOK. TO BECOME MORE
FINANCIALLY LITERATE. AND
ESPECIALLY AS MANY OF THEM ARE
LOOKING TO TAKE ON STUDENT
LOANS. AND DIDN'T YOU KNOW BY
YOU GET CREDIT CARDS AND TAKE
COMPLEX FINANCIAL DECISIONS. I
THINK. IT WOULD BE REALLY USEFUL
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
INTRODUCTORY. COURSE TO
FINANCIAL LITERACY TO. SHOW THEM
WHERE THE RESOURCES ARE BECAUSE-
I DON'T THINK THAT THE SAME
LEVEL OF APATHY IS THERE FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY. I THINK-
PROVIDING ACCESSIBILITY FOR
THESE COURSES. IS GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL ESPECIALLY TO THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED- AND
THEN I THINK THE PART ABOUT
ENGAGEMENT- WHAT WHEN WE MAKE
DE. THE COURSE. BUT WHEN WE MAKE
IT TAILORED TO THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES I THINK WILL
NATURALLY FEEL MORE INCLINED TO
BE ENGAGED BECAUSE- IT REFLECTS.
HOW THEY'LL DO LATER ON IN LIFE
. SO I ALSO LOVE THIS IDEA I
THINK THAT FINANCIAL LITERACY IS
JUST OF THE MOST CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE- WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL
BACK IN THE DARK AGES WE HAD AN
ECONOMICS CLASS. AND IN THAT
ECONOMICS CLASS OUR INSTRUCTOR I
STILL REMEMBER SHE TAUGHT US HOW
TO DO SOMETHING WHICH I'M SURE
NONE OF YOU KNOW HOW TO DO WHICH
IS TO WRITE A CHECK- AND HOW TO
PAY YOUR BILLS. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT- YOU KNOW RENT AND WAGES
AND IF YOU MAKE THIS MUCH WHAT
CAN YOU AFFORD AND I DO THINK
THAT THAT IS LACKING- BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC ON TEAM NAY BUT WE
WOULD ALWAYS HAVE A YOUNG
WOMEN'S AND A YOUNG MEN'S
CONFERENCE. EACH YEAR AT OUR-
LAST I BELIEVE IS OUR LAST TEN
MINS CONFERENCE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WE HAD ABOUT. A LITTLE
OVER TWO HUNDRED YOUNG MEN THAT
WE DID SOMETHING CALLED MAD CITY
MONEY AND IT WAS PUT ON AND I
THINK THIS WOULD BE- GREAT IN
ALL OF OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AND EVEN
IN OUR JUNIOR HIGHS- IS PUT ON
BY A- CREDIT UNION. AND SO THE
YOUNG MEN WERE PAIRED UP AND
THEY WERE A COUPLE THAT WERE
EACH GIVEN A PROFESSION AND HOW
MUCH THEY MADE IT THAT
PROFESSION THEY WERE GIVEN- SOME
HAD CHILDREN SOME DID NOT HAVE
CHILDREN. AND THEN THEY WERE
TOLD THAT THEY HAD NINE ARE
ELEVEN DIFFERENT SPOTS TO GO TO
AND THEY HAD THREE CHOICES OF
HOW MUCH RENT THEY WANT TO PAY
WHAT KIND OF CAR THEY WANT TO
DRIVE OR DO THEY WANT TO TAKE A
BUS TO SAVE MONEY- HOW MUCH IS
SPENT. ON FOOD HOW MUCH CHILD
CARE WAS IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING AND I WAS WORRIED TO
DOCTOR PANTS FOR A POINT THAT
THESE YOUNG MEN MIGHT NOT FIND
IT ENGAING BUT THEY ALL DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB AND I WANT ONE OF
THE- THAT THE TWO THAT WERE
PAIRED UP THEY CAME OVER AND
SAID. OKAY WHERE DO WE GO FOR
COUNSELLING BECAUSE WE'RE
FIGHTING AND- AND I THOUGHT THAT
WAS GREAT AND VERY ACCURATE WHAT
HAPPENS IN LIFE SO I DO REALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT- AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS ISN'T THE END OF THIS
PARTICULAR CREDIT UNION WOULD DO
IT. ANYWHERE BUT- LET ME NOODLE
ON THAT A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU. YOU
KNOW YOU YOU'RE GROWING UP AND-
YOU KNOW. YOU HAVE A ROOF OVER
YOUR HEAD SO. HOPEFULLY AND YOU
HAVE FOOD ON THE TABLE AND A LOT
OF TIMES ON YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW. WHAT THE COST OF THAT IS
THE COST OF KEEPING THE LIGHTS
ON- THAT A MINIMUM WAGE JOB AT
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR IS
ACTUALLY A POVERTY WAGE JOBS- SO
I THINK THIS IS JUST CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS WELL SO I. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL A WE'LL
LOOK AT THE THEY THINK THERE ARE
TWO BILLS MOVING IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THAT ADDRESS THIS AND
SO MAYBE AS THEY COME OVER
HOPEFULLY TO. SENATE EDUCATION-
WE CAN WORK ON MAY BE INSERTING
SOMETHING- WITH THIS MAD CITY
MONEY. PROGRAM I THINK THAT IT
WOULD- WE DID WITH OUR YOUNG MEN
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE WANT OUR YOUNG
WOMEN TO BENEFIT FROM THAT TOO
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EXCELLENT TOPIC AN EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME YOU ARE QUITE
WELCOME. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE ARE
GOING TO OUR LAST PROVOKE
PROPOSAL WHICH WILL BE PRESENTED
BY CHRISTY TO. IS IT TOO OR TOW
CHRISTINE. TELL VERY GOOD THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE YOUR STUDENT
AT NORTHWOOD HIGH SCHOOL. PLEASE
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
IS THEMEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CHRISTY TELL AND I'M FROM THE
SIXTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
THIRTY SEVEN SENATE DISTRICT.
AND I'M A SOPHOMORE AT NORTHWOOD
HIGH SCHOOL. ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION. WE
PROPOSE THAT ONE THIRD OF SCHOOL
SITE COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP. BE
COMPOSED OF STUDENTS. IN ORDER
FOR STUDENTS TO HAVE AN ACTIVE
VOICE IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES. OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS AND OTHER SCHOOL SAFETY
RELATED TOPICS. UPON DISCUSSION
WITH MY PEERS I WAS SHOCKED TO
LEARN THAT OTHER STUDENTS SHARE
THE SAME FEELINGS OF EASE THAT I
WAS EXPERIENCING CONCERNING MY
SAFETY AT SCHOOL. HI MY HIGH
SCHOOL NORTHWOOD HIGH SCHOOL IN
ORANGE COUNTY STUDENTS HAVE LOVE
CLASSES DUE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IN THE CLASSROOM. LEAVING MY
PEERS AND I IN CONSTANT FEAR OF
THE DANGERS AT SCHOOL. I FEEL
HOPELESS BECAUSE MY SCHOOL'S
FACULTY HAVE NOT TAKEN PROPER
SAFETY MEASURES TO COMBAT THESE
DANGERS. MANY STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF NOW DO NOT FEEL SAFE
GOING TO SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THIS
. SIMILARLY A CUPERTINO HIGH
SCHOOL AND HOMES AT HIGH SCHOOL
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY THERE HAS
BEEN A BOMB THREAT IN SEVERAL
INSTANCES OF STUDENTS BRINGING
GUNS ON CAMPUS. AT WEST VALLEY
HIGH SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
STUDENT FIGHTS NEAR CAMPUS HAVE
ESCALATED INTO SHOOTINGS THAT
CAUSED THE SCHOOL TO GO ON
LOCKDOWN. SCHOOL A PLACE THAT
SHE FOSTER STUDENT DEVELOPMENT
AND LEARNING THIS SAFE AND
PROTECTED ENVIRONMENT HAS BECOME
A PLACE OF FEAR FOR STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
PLATFORM TO VOICE THEIR SAFETY
CONCERNS. IT IS APPARENT THAT TO
A LOT OF STUDENT REPRESENTATION
IN SETTING SCHOOL SAFETY
GUIDELINES THE CURRENT SCHOOL
SAFETY GUIDELINES DO NOT
ADEQUATELY REPRESENT STUDENT
NEEDS. CALIFORNIA REQUIRES EVERY
PUBLIC SCHOOL TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS THAT IS APPROVED BY EACH
SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL WHICH IS A
DECISION MAKING GROUP OF
EDUCATION PARTNERS OF THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. HOWEVER THESE PENS
RARELY INCLUDE STUDENT INPUT AND
FAIL TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS. INSTEAD THEY
ADDRESS ADULTS PERCEIVED THREATS
TO SCHOOL SAFETY. THEREFORE WE
NEED MORE STUDENT REPRESENTATION
TO MAINTAIN ACCOUNTABILITY IN
OUR SCHOOL SAFETY GUIDELINES. IN
CALIFORNIA THE RISE OF VIOLENCE
WITHIN SCHOOLS HAS CREATED A
GROWING MOVEMENT FOR BETTER
REGULATION OF SCHOOL SAFETY BALK
AT THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL.
AMID THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING
SEVERE THREATS TO THEIR PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL SAFETY. HAVING MORE
STUDENT VOICES IN SCHOOL SITE
COUNCILS WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE
ADVOCACY FOR STUDENT PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL SAFETY. SENIOR
REPRESENTATION IN SCHOOL SITE
COUNCILS IS ESSENTIAL TO MOVE
PAST THE UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS IN
SCHOOLS TODAY. IN LIGHT OF THESE
OBSERVATIONS WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
SOLUTION. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
GIVE STUDENTS A PLATFORM BY
HAVING AT LEAST ONE THIRD OF
SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL MEMBERSHIPS
BE COMPOSED OF STUDENTS. A
SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL IS A
DECISION MAKING BODY THAT
REPRESENTS ALL EDUCATION
PARTNERS OF THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY
OF EQUAL AMOUNTS OF
ADMINISTRATORS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. STUDENTS SERVING ON THE
COUNCIL SHOULD BE GRANTED MANY
OF THE SAME PRIVILEGES AS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION STAFF AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVING THE
ABILITY TO VOICE CONCERNS AND
MAKE CHANGES ON THE TOPIC OF
SCHOOL SAFETY. IN ADDITION
STUDENTS ON THE COUNCIL WOULD
OVERSEE THE CREATION AND
APPROVAL OF EACH SCHOOLS
DISTRICTS ANNUAL COMPREHENSIVE
SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN. TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR RESPECTIVE STUDENT
BODIES FEEL THAT THEIR WELL
BEING IS A HIGH PRIORITY. DUE TO
THE NATURE OF THIS PROPOSAL THIS
PLAN WILL REQUIRE NO COST. THIS
SOLUTION ALLOWS SCHOOL SITES AND
DISTRICTS TO CREATE AND ADOPT
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS BASED ON
THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS WELL
ACTIVELY INCORPORATING STUDENT
INPUT TO ENSURE EACH CAMPUS
PRIORITIZE A SCHOOL SAFETY. AND
MANY SHOOTERS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
PURSUE OPEN DIALOGUE WITH THEIR
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
OF ESTABLISHING THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS BY PROVIDING FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION ACCESSIBLE TO THE
ENTIRE STUDENT BODY. SIXTY IS
ESSENTIAL TO OPTIMIZING LEARNING
AS WELL AS STUDENT STAFF
RELATIONSHIPS THEREFORE
PRIORITIZING STUDENT
REPRESENTATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS AND PROTOCOLS WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING GIVEN A
VOICE TO REPRESENT THEMSELVES
WITHIN THEIR SAFETY AND THEIR
EDUCATION. OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
IS ONE THAT VALUES STUDENT
SAFETY AND SUCCESS SO WE HOPE
THAT SCHOOL SITE COUNCILS HAVING
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF SEAT
REPRESENTATION WILL UPHOLD THIS
BELIEF. I STUDENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE TO FEEL
PROTECTED AND COMFORTABLE WHEN
LEARNING. WITH THIS PLAN
STUDENTS WILL BE EMPOWERED TO
TAKE CHARGE OF THEIR OWN SAFETY
AND SUCCEED IN AN IMPROVED
ENVIRONMENT THAT PRIORITIZES
THEIR WELL BEING THANK YOU. YOU
VERY MUCH EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION- CENTER PANDA
GERMANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- GOOD IT IS A
FIRST OF ALL- DOWN THE DATA ON
VIOLENCE IN SCHOOLS- ACTUALLY I
THINK- WAS PRETTY COVE IT WAS
ACTUALLY I THINK- HEADING
DOWNWARD BUT- WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE GOOD DATA POST CODE- AND
UNFORTUNATELY I MEAN IT IT
ANECDOTALLY IT'S UP. AND IT
SEEMS TO BE UP THIS OR RELATED
TO ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY
INCREASE VIOLENCE IN THE GENERAL
COMMUNITY- AND- AND
UNFORTUNATELY ALSO- SOMETIMES
PARENTS DON'T MODEL THE PROGRAM
BEHAVIOR WITH SCHOOL LEADERS
WHAT IT SCHOOL BOARD SOURCE
TEACHERS OR SCHOOL LEADERS AS
WELL AND THAT OF COURSE
PROBLEMS. SOME STUDENTS TEND TO
IMITATE THOSE PARENTS AND THEN.
ENGAGE AND WHETHER IT'S
THREATENING BEHAVIOR VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR SO I THINK THAT
SOMETHING TO BE YOU KNOW THE
FORTUNE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DRESS AS WELL IT'S- IT'S
NOT STUDENTS PARENTS THAT-
THERE'S NOT SHOWING RESPECT TO
THEIR SCHOOL LEADERS AND-
ENGAGING IN. INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE CASES OF THAT AND INDEED
FOR PUBLIC FORMS UNFORTUNATELY.
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE STUDENTS MUCH MORE ENGAGED
AFTER ALL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SAFETY YOU KNOW IT'S A IT IS
ABOUT STUDENTS ABOUT SPIT OUT
THE TEACHERS AND STAFF BUT I
MEAN STUDENTS ARE VERY MUCH PART
OF THAT AND NEED TO BE ENGAGED
IN HELPING DEVELOP SOLUTIONS.
AND OFTEN TIMES- WITH SUITS
SOLUTIONS BEING DEVELOPED
WITHOUT THE HMO STUDENTS YOU CAN
END UP WITH EVEN SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW HARMFUL US- SOLUTION SO FOR
EXAMPLE- CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
HIS CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL IT'S A- THE- GUN
VIOLENCE INCIDENT AND THEN THE
SCHOOL RIGHT. BUT THE ANSWER IS
NOT NECESSARILY TO HAVE IT
DRILLED WHERE UNFORTUNATELY ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE DAY. HAD
TEACHERS YOU KNOW THEY HAD TO
JUST PRETEND LIKE THEY WERE SHOT
BY PEOPLE I MEAN THAT THAT WAS
REALLY TRAUMATIC FOR THE
STUDENTS TO HAVE TO WITNESS
THAT- IS BUSY PART OF THE DRILL
RIGHT IT WAS- AND SO FORTH. AND
I'M NOT SURE WHO WOULD THINK
THAT WAS A ACTUALLY A GOOD IDEA-
AND THAT AND THEN OF WE NEED TO
BE SURE WE SHOULD THAT THAT THE-
YEAH. ITS AT THE- PEOPLE ARE
DEVELOPING THESE PLANS ARE TO
THE STUDENTS. ALL RIGHT AT THE
THEIR FEARS IT DIDN'T NOT JUST
THE MAN ARE FEARS BUT WHAT THE
ACTUALLY THE ACTUAL. ARE SO I
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT- AND- I
MEAN WE NEED TO HAVE GOOD DATA
SO WE KNOW WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON AT BUT ALSO SAFETY IS
PARTIALLY PERCEPTION TOO SO WE
NEED TO BE SURE. PROBABLY
DEALING WITH PERCEPTION AND THEN
OF COURSE WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
STANDARDS OF BEHAVIOR FOR
EVERYONE. RIGHT EVERYONE WHO'S
ON HIS ENGAGING IN THE SCHOOL
AND THE SCHOOL CAMPUSES SO THAT
AND BOB ISN'T ENGAGING THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY SO CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW WE CAN TALK ABOUT
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS AND
PRINCIPLES AND OTHER SCHOOL
LEADERS BUT IF AGAIN IF THE
COMMUNITY ITSELF IS NOT MODELING
THE KIND OF THE THAT TYPE
BEHAVIOR THAT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY HARD. FOR THINGS IN
SCHOOL SO- REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS PRESENTATION- AND- I THINK
YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE
GET STUDENTS MUCH MORE. IN IN
DEVELOPMENT SCHOOLS SCHOOL
SAFETY PLANS AND- AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
AND- YOUR YOUR SUGGESTION. IT
SUGGESTIONS. FOR ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN- I ECHO IT A CENTER.
BECAUSE ABOUT. BEHAVIOR BEING
MODELED- BY PARENTS NOT ALL
PARENTS BUT I HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND SOME
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS AND- IN MY
DISTRICT IN RECENT MONTHS. AND
TO SAY I AM APPALLED- WOULD BE.
ACCURATE AND IT'S JUST I. D. YOU
STUDENTS GIVE ME HOPE FOR THE
FUTURE. BECAUSE WHEN I SEE
PARENTS- PARADING AROUND YELLING
AND SCREAMING AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS. I HONESTLY I FEEL BAD
FOR THEM BECAUSE NO ONE HAS
TAUGHT THEM IN THEIR LIFE THAT
THAT IS NOT HOW YOU GET THINGS
DONE- YOU CAN BE ANGRY. YOU
COULD BE UPSET AND YOU COULD
WANT CHANGE BUT THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO IT AND ALL
OF YOU ARE MODELING THAT
BEHAVIOR. AND I'VE SEEN THAT THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS TO- IS
WHERE THE STUDENTS HAVE MODELED
THE BEHAVIOR AND THE PARENTS
SHOULD TAKE HEED AND EVEN SOME
OF THE TEACHERS HAVE BEEN. OUT
OF LINE AS WELL. SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THAT AREA-
YOU SHOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE AND
SAFE AT SCHOOL. AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS WORKED ON A LOT OF
HARASSMENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ISSUES AND BILLS SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE- IT TROUBLES ME TO HEAR
THAT YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE BEING
SEXUALLY HARASSED. AT SCHOOL-
AGAIN A LOT OF THAT COMES FROM
HOME AND ARE WE TEACHING OUR
YOUNG MEN TO BE GOOD YOUNG MEN.
AND ARE WE TEACHING OUR YOUNG
WOMEN TO HOW TO HOW DO YOU REACT
TO THOSE THINGS- AND A BUT I
JUST. THAT BOTHERS ME THAT THAT
THAT YOU FEEL THAT YOU'RE
SEXUALLY HARASSED IN HIGH
SCHOOL. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO AS A LEGISLATURE- AND OF
COURSE JUST FEELING SAFE AND
WORRYING ABOUT A GUN BEING
BROUGHT TO SCHOOL AND- AND
LOSING YOUR LIFE- WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO AS- A STATE. AND
AS A COUNTRY SO THANK YOU FOR
THE WELL THOUGHT OUT PROPOSAL- I
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE IT AND
WE WILL WE WILL TAKE IT ALL TO
HEART. THANK YOU MISTER. SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHTWE'RE GOING TO
HEAR SOME CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
IS STEPHANIE WHO SABLES
EDUCATION POLICY POLICY DIRECTOR
WELCOME BACK TO THE PODIUM YEAH-
I'D LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK THE
ESTEEMED CHAIR BERMAN LEYVA AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION FOR
LISTENING TO OUR PROPOSALS FOR
THIS YEAR'S STABLE CONFERENCE I
SINCERELY HOPE THAT VERY SHORTLY
WE CAN TURN THESE IDEAS KICK
STARTED IN YOUR ROOM AND ACTIONS
IMPLEMENTED BY YOU THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EDUCATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
PRESENTERS AND TO ALL OF THE
STUDENTS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
ANY FURTHER MEMBER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WHO WANTS TO
PARTICIPATE TO COLIN NOW PLEASE
DIAL THIS TOLL FREE NUMBER.
844-291-4185 WHAT PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS CODE. ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO-
CENTER PANDER HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. I JUST REALLY WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO COME HERE AND PRESENT TO
US ODAY- SOME REALLY FANTASTIC
IDEAS AND I KNOW YOU SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WORKING ON THE BEFORE
YOU CAME HERE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- AND- EATERS
THOUGHTFULNESS AND ALL AND ALL
THESE IDEAS I KNOW IT IN A NEED
TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROPOSAL BUT I
MEAN IT'S ALSO STICKS IN THE
OUTSTANDING IDEA. AS WELL AND
THAT THINKING ABOUT LIKE HOW HOW
DO WE MAKE THAT HAPPEN ONLY FOR
THE SCHOOL BUT ALSO HOW DO WE BE
SURE THAT THE CITY WHO AFTER
OPERATE THE DATA YOU KNOW WHO
MAY HAVE THE CONTRACTOR OPERATES
TOTALLY A WASTE MANAGEMENT
DEPARTMENT HOW THE WORKING WITH
THE SCHOOL SO IT'S ADDRESS SO
AGAIN REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TAKING THE TIME OUT THAT BUT NOT
JUST THE TIME YOU SPENT HERE
PRESENTED TO US BUT- EVEN
GREATER AMOUNT OF TIME YOU SPENT
PUTTING THESE PEOPLE TOGETHER
GETTING FEEDBACK FROM YOUR
PEERS. AND THEN REALLY
ORGANIZING AND- AND THEN
THINKING THE SUIT. THESE THINGS
THROUGH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN I HAVE TO AGREE A
HERE FOR. TO US IS ONE. BUT IT'S
THE TIME YOU PUT IN AND THE
THOUGHT. AND IT'S JUST EVIDENT
THAT ALL OF YOU SINCERELY CARE
ABOUT THESE ISSUES. AND THE
ISSUES THAT WILL AFFECT EVERYONE
IN YOUR SCHOOLS. AND IN SCHOOLS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO LIKE I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING THIS IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS- IN
SENATE EDUCATION IS HEARING FROM
ALL OF YOU. AS I ALSO JUST SAID
OUR FUTURE IS BRIGHT WITH ALL OF
YOU AND AS I TELL STUDENTS WHEN
I GO AND SPEAK TO THEM HIGH
SCHOOL. YOU ALL HAVE A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY YOU HAVE TO AND
SCRIPT THE WORLD. THAT WE ADULTS
HAVE SCREWED UP BUT I HAVE FAITH
IN ALL OF YOU. SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ANYONE AT
FORTY TWO OH THREE HERE THAT ONE
WISHES TO SPEAK. ABOUT THE ANY
OF THE ISSUES BROUGHT FORWARD.
SEEING NO ONE. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO YOU AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. AND
COMMENT ON THE- THE PROPOSALS WE
JUST HEARD. THANK YOU OUR LADY
GERMAN THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING UP ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD DON'T TAKE THAT
AS A NEGATIVE THING- EVEN THOUGH
IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS WE STILL
HAVE PEOPLE GETTING USED TO A
NEW WAY OF DOING BUSINESS. AND
WATCHING AND THEN CALLING IN I
WILL ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU ALL
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'RE DOING IF YOU EVER NEED
ANYTHING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE OR THE ASSEMBLY.
PLEASE ASK US YOU DO PAY OUR
SALARY THROUGH YOUR TAXES SO PUT
US TO WORK- THEN THAT ME JUST
CONCLUDE BY SAYING THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO-
PARTICIPATED TODAY IF YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA THE-
TELECONFERENCE OR WAS. PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU CENTER PAN FOR HANGING
IN THERE WITH ME. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
OUR AGENDA AND THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
. THANK YOU ALL.